in this
very chamber to stop you
to stop us
i'd respectfully ask that you remember
those three phrases
as you consider the evidence today
election was stolen stop the steal
and fight like hell because they did not
just appear
on january 6th let me show you
what i mean let's start with the big lie
you will see
during this trial that the president
realized really
by last spring that he could lose he
might lose
the election so what did he do
he started planting the seeds to get
some of his supporters
ready by saying that he could only lose
the election
if it was stolen i mean in other words
really what he did is
create a no lose scenario either he won
the election or
he would have some angry supporters not
all
but some who believed
that if he lost the election had to be
rigged
and they would be angry
because he was telling americans that
their vote had been stolen
and in america our vote is our voice
so his false claims about election fraud
that was the drum beat being used to
inspire
instigate and ignite them
to anger them watch this clip
because we're not going to let this
election be taken away from us that's
the only way they're going to win it
we're not going to let it happen it's
the only way
we can be it's the only way we can lose
in my opinion is
massive fraud
we all know what happened after that
he lost he lost the election
but remember he had that no lose
scenario that i referenced earlier
he told his base that the election was
stolen
as he had forecasted and then he told
them
your election has been stolen but you
cannot concede
you must stop the steel
you can't let another person steal that
election from you
all over the country people are together
in holding up signs stop
this deal the democrats are trying to
steal the white house
you cannot let them you just can't let
them
now while he's inciting
his supporters he's also simultaneously
doing everything he possibly can to
overturn the election
first he begins with the courts a
legitimate evidence
legitimate avenue to challenge the
election
but he ignores all of their adverse
rulings
when all of his claims are thrown out
then he moves on to trying to pressure
state election officials
to block the election results for his
opponent
even though he'd lost in their states
you'll hear
my fellow managers discuss that in
detail then he tries
to threaten state election officials to
actually change the votes
to make him the winner even threatening
criminal penalties
[Music]
if they refused he had the justice
department
investigate his claims even they found
no support for those claims so he tried
to persuade
some members of his party in congress to
block the certification of his vote with
attacks
in public forums when that failed
he tried to intimidate the vice
president of the united states
of america to refuse to certify the vote
and send it back to the states
none of it worked so
what does he do with his back against
the wall
when all else has failed
he turns back to his supporters who
he'd already spent months telling them
that the election was stolen
and he amplified it further he turned it
up a notch
he told them that they had to be ready
not just to stop the steel
but to fight like hell
we're in a fight for the survival of our
nation and we are going to keep on
fighting
we will never surrender we will only win
now is not the time to retreat now is
the time to fight
harder than ever before we have to go
all the way and we're going to fight
like hell i'll tell you right now
we will not bend we will not break we
will not yield
we will never give in we will never give
up we will
never back down we will never ever
surrender
you will see that in the months
as the president made these statements
people listened armed supporters
surrounded election officials homes
the secretary of state for georgia got
death threats
officials warned the president that his
rhetoric
was dangerous and it was going to result
in deadly violence and
that's what makes this so different
because when he
saw firsthand the violence that his
conduct was creating
he didn't stop it he didn't condemn the
violence
he incited it further and he got more
specific
he didn't just tell them to fight like
hell he told them how
where and when he made sure they had
advanced notice
18 days advance notice he sent his save
the date
for january sixth he told them to march
to the capitol
and fight like hell on january sixth is
lead manager raskin said the exact same
day that we were certifying
the election results what time
was that rally scheduled for the exact
same time
that this chamber was certifying the
election results in joint session when
did he conclude
his speech literally moments before
speaker pelosi
had gaveled us into session
many of us were in the house during that
joint session of congress
i was sitting two rows behind leader
schumer
and leader mcconnell i remember it
vividly
and as we were standing there fulfilling
our solemn oath
to the constitution the president was
finishing his speech just a couple of
miles away
how did he conclude that infamous speech
with a final call to action
he told them to march down pennsylvania
avenue
to come here that it was their patriotic
duty
because the election had been stolen
and when they heard his speech they
understood
his words and what they meant because
they had heard it before
let's take just a minute and really look
at his words on january 6th
as he spoke at the save america rally
now remember i told you
you hear three phrases the election was
stolen stop the steal
and fight like hell let's start with
that first phrase
all of us here today do not want to see
our election victory stolen
there's never been anything like this
it's a pure theft in american history
everybody knows it
make no mistake this election was stolen
from you
from me and from the country
now of course each of you heard those
words before
so had the crowd the president had spent
months
telling his supporters that the election
had been stolen and
stolen and he used this speech to incite
them further to inflame them
to stop the steel to stop
the certification of the election
results
we will never give up we will never
concede it doesn't happen you don't
concede when there's theft involved
and to use a favorite term that all of
you people really came
up with we will stop the steal
we must stop this deal
finally the president used
this speech as a call to arms
it was not rhetorical
some of his supporters had been primed
for this
over many months as you'll learn
days before this speech as lead manager
raskin
noted there were vast reports across all
major media outlets that thousands of
people
would be armed that they'd be violent
you'll learn the capitol police and the
fbi
reported in the days leading up to the
attack
that thousands in the crowd would be
targeting the capital specifically
that they had arrested people with guns
the night before the attack
on weapons charges and this
is what our commander-in-chief said
to the crowd in the face of those
warnings
right before they came here we will not
let them silence your voices we're not
going to let it happen
not gonna let it happen
[Applause]
thank you and you have to get your
people
to fight because you'll never
take back our country with weakness you
have to show
strength and you have to be strong and
we fight
we fight like hell and if you don't
fight like hell you're not gonna have a
country anymore
you have to get your people
to fight he told them
senators this clearly was not just one
speech
it didn't just happen it was part of a
carefully planned
months long effort with a very specific
instruction show up on january 6th
and get your people to fight the
certification
he incited it it was foreseeable
and again you don't have to take
my word for it the president's former
chief of staff
is a retired marine four-star general
was confirmed by this body to be the
secretary of homeland
security overwhelmingly overwhelming
vote
that man was john kelly and on the day
after the insurrection
he said this you know the president
knows
who he's talking to when he tweets so
when he makes
statements he knows who he's talking to
who knows what
uh he wants them to do and uh the fact
that
he said the things he's been saying the
things he's been saying since the
election
um and encouraging people no surprise
again uh
what happened yesterday
no surprise think about that no surprise
the president had every reason to know
that this would happen because he
assembled the mob
he summoned the mob and he incited
the mob he knew when he
took that podium on that fateful
morning that those in attendance had
heeded his words
and they were waiting for his orders to
begin fighting
and that of course brings me hey
everybody so i am here
um it's been an insane day i'm not
working off of my normal
uh setup i i am in the sun room today so
i'm gonna do the best i can to get
everything
set up and going i'm glad to see
everybody i'm glad everybody's here and
we are on
sort of day one sort of day two of the
second trump impeachment trial yesterday
was day one but it was really just
a day to decide whether they can hold
the trial as insane as that is
and um so i'm going to talk about a
couple of different things and then
there's going to be hours and hours and
hours of this so so
don't worry we're we're going to be just
just fine i don't have super chats on
screen right now
i am seeing them and i am getting them i
see that mark fillion
said uh considering the outcome of the
impeachment could we just get it over
and make sure that congress and senate
are focusing on the relief package
um an interesting comment and an
interesting an interesting question
i uh i actually have another monitor
that i'm hoping to set up for tomorrow
so i can get super chats
on screen but i need a little tech help
from you guys
um i have my lap i'm working off my
laptop which has one hdmi port
so i've got one monitor connected i have
a second
monitor but i don't have a second hdmi
port
so is there some kind of either
um dvi or hdmi
usb thing that will give me the ability
to plug in
another monitor if so if somebody can
let me know
what that is i can get it and then
tomorrow i can get uh get that set up
let's take a listen to this i want to
hear what this is all about and then
i'm going to get back to a few other
things you heard it
from them they were doing
what he wanted them to do
they wouldn't have listened to you to me
to the vice president of the united
states who they were attacking
they didn't stop in the face of law
enforcement
police officers fighting for their lives
to stop them
they were following the president
he alone our commander-in-chief had
the power to stop it and he didn't
you will hear evidence tonight tomorrow
throughout the trial about his refusal
as commander-in-chief to respond to
numerous
desperate police on the phone across
social media
begging him to stop the attack
and you will see his relentless attack
on vice president pence
who was at that very moment hiding with
his family
as armed extremists were chanting hang
mike pence
calling him a traitor
you will see that even when he did
finally three and a half hours into the
attack
tell these people to go home
in peace he added
as lead manager asking said i'll quote
you're very special we love you
think for a moment just a moment
of the lives lost that day
of the more than 140 wounded police
officers
and ask yourself if as soon as this
had started president trump had simply
gone on to tv
just logged onto twitter and said stop
the attack
if he had done so with even half as much
force
as he said stop the steal
how many lives would we have saved
sadly he didn't do that
at the end of the day the president was
not
successful in stopping the certification
that we know thanks to the brave okay
for people asking about my
second monitor thing i have a dell pc
i do have an extra usb port
i have what looks like usbc it just has
a little lightning
thing next to it and then i have
another usb so i'm working with two usbs
and something that
looks like usbc that's what i've that's
what i've got available
work in the capital our staff
your staff to our brave capitol police
who defend us tirelessly with little
thanks
who believed that they had a
commander-in-chief who would defend
and protect them and instead put them in
harm's way
to those killed for heeding
his command to our democracy and the
system
which ensures that we have a president
elected by the people
to our national security and our
standing in the world
the harm was real the damage
was real five people
lost their lives on that terrible tragic
day a woman was shot
dead 50 feet
from where we later certified the
election results
and for those who question just how bad
it was
criminal complaints recently unsealed by
the department of justice
are more than revealing you'll see one
of these documents
on the screen in the charging affidavit
of one of the leaders of the proud boys
we learned
that members of this group said i'm
going to quote
they would have killed mike pence
if given the chance
in another we learned of a tweet in real
time
while they were in the building stating
we broke into the capitol
we got inside we did our part
we were looking for nancy pelosi to
shoot her in the freaking brain but we
didn't find
her
[Music]
and for anyone who suggests otherwise
these defendants themselves
have told you exactly why they were here
you'll see this in the trial that in the
halls of the capital on social media
in news interviews and in charging
documents they
confirm they were following
the president's orders you can see some
of the statements on that screen
one who said trump wants all able-bodied
patriots another that president trump is
calling us to fight this is
all right guys last interruption on this
tech thing people who want all the data
i have a dell vostro 7590
okay and the monitor
is this what is this thing this is a
dell
wait what is this dell
uh oh god this thing is old it only has
dvi and vga
so oh my god
this is oh this is a this is a that's an
old monitor
um yeah so i guess i need like
thunderbolt to
dvi or something it's almost simpler to
just get a different monitor all right
let's continue
and seeing many of you there i remember
us finishing our task
at four in the morning and as of
as i walked off the floor i was so
grateful so grateful for the opportunity
to thank the vice president of the
united states
mike pence for his actions
for standing before us and asking us to
follow our oath
and our faith and our duty
we only got a couple hours of sleep that
morning
early the next day i called my dad
who came to this country as i mentioned
as an immigrant 40 years ago
and i told him that the proudest moment
by far
of serving in congress for me
was going back onto the floor with each
of you
to finish the work that we had started
i'm humbled
to be back with you today and just
as on january 6th when we overcame that
attack
on our capital on our country
i'm hopeful that at this trial we can
use
our resolve and our resilience to again
uphold our democracy by faithfully
applying the law
vindicating the constitution and holding
president trump accountable
for his actions
[Music]
so there's congressman goose the goose
uh senators um representatives
joaquin castro and eric swalwell will
now
show the evidence of president trump's
long campaign to deliver
delegitimize delegitimizes electoral
defeat and to galvanize his supporters
to
help him retain his power at any cost so
we're going to go at this point
step by step and explain the progression
all the way up
until the attack raskin's fantastic
swalwell is a friend of the david pakman
show
good guy um
all very well organized
thanks to astro lycos for gifting five
subs on twitch we're keeping up with
everything
trisha eastman seven months thank you
[Music]
strong start today here
good afternoon y'all my name is joaquin
gosselin i represent san antonio
in the united states congress
there's a saying that a lie can travel
halfway around the world
before the truth has a chance to put on
its shoes
that was before the internet
the point of that saying is that a lie
can do incredible damage
and destruction and that's especially
true
when that lie is told by the most
powerful person on earth
our commander-in-chief the president
of the united states
[Music]
this attack did not come from one speech
and it didn't happen by accident the
evidence shows clearly
that this mob was provoked over many
months by donald j
trump and if you look at the evidence
his purposeful conduct
you'll see that the attack was
foreseeable and preventable
[Music]
i'll start by discussing president
trump's actions leading up to the
election
when he set up his big lie
beginning in the spring of 2020
president trump began
to fall behind in the polls and by july
president trump had reached a new low he
was running 15 points
behind his opponent and he was scared
he began to believe that he could
legitimately lose the election
and so he did something entirely
unprecedented
in the history of our nation
he refused to commit to a peaceful
transition
of power here's what he said
[Music]
can you give a direct answer you will
accept the election look
you i have to see oh i'm not going to
just say yes i'm not going to say no
[Music]
do you commit to making sure that
there's a peaceful plan
get rid of the ballots and you'll have a
very trans we'll have a very peaceful
no balance be a transfer frankly
there'll be a continuation
[Music]
senators the president of the united
states said quote
there won't be a transition of power
there'll be a continuation
president trump was given every
opportunity to tell his supporters
yes if i lose i will peacefully transfer
power
to the next president guys by the way
i can see the super chats they're just
not up on the screen nothing's wrong
with the super chats i just want to get
them up on the screen for you guys for
tomorrow with another monitor but i can
see them
i see dan and keith and abhinav and
everybody possibly be true
but that was the point he didn't care if
the claims were true
he wanted to make sure that his
supporters were angry
like the election was being ripped away
from them
on may 24th six months before the
election
he tweeted it will be the greatest
rigged election in history the best one
how could he possibly know it would be
the greatest rigged election in history
six months before the election happened
and on june 22nd more of the same
rig 2020 election it will be the scandal
of our times
again about an election that had not
even
happened
on july 30th 2020 will be the most
inaccurate and fraudulent election
in history again
just big words with nothing to prove
them
but he wanted to make his supporters
believe that election victory
would be stolen from him and from them
this was to rile up his base to make
them angry
now these were just a few of the many
times
president trump tweeted about this and
he did it in speeches
rallies and in television too
this is going to be the greatest
election disaster in history
because the only way we're going to lose
this election
is if the election is rigged remember
that
the only way they can take this election
away from us
is if this is a rigged election we're
going to win this election
it's a rigged election it's the only way
we're going to lose but this will be one
of the greatest fraudulent most
fraudulent elections fraudulent
[Music]
this is clearly a man who refuses to
accept
the possibility or the reality
in our democracy of losing an election
there are dozens more tweets and
speeches of donald trump spreading his
lie
but you get the point his supporters got
the point as well
they firmly believe that if he lost it
was because the election was rigged
will you accept the result of joe biden
wins no
under any circumstance no why is that
this is michael shore lies
and deceit and corruption that's friend
of the show michael jordan
who was asking that question following
days if biden winds up
somehow becoming the winner do you think
it's rigged oh yes
very much yes days after
if it shows up that joe biden won yes in
your opinion would that
be the only way that trump could lose
that would be a rigged election
is that the only way you can win
absolutely i agree with that
because there's no way in heck our
president is going to lose but yes
it would be a real election there was
some type of cheating went
on what have you and i i firmly believe
that
can you imagine now all of us in this
room
have run for election and it's no fun to
lose
but sometimes i'm a texas democrat
sometimes you lose we've lost a few
elections over the years
but can you imagine telling your
supporters
that the only way you could possibly
lose is if an american election
was rigged and stolen from you
and ask yourself whether you've ever
seen
anyone at any level of government
make the same claim about their own
election
[Music]
but that's exactly what president trump
did
he truly made his base believe that the
only way he could lose
was if the election was rigged and
senators
all of us know and all of us understand
how dangerous that is for our country
because the most combustible thing you
can do in a democracy
is convince people that an election
doesn't count
that their voice and their vote don't
count
and that it's all been stolen especially
if what you're saying are lies
[Music]
let us turn now to the election right
as you know the results were not fully
reported on election night
which is not unusual in our nation's
history
but by november 7th major news networks
including fox news
reported that once the remaining votes
were counted
joe biden would be the likely victor
so president trump began urging his
supporters
to stop the count
i would imagine that if we went around
this room
there are folks sitting here that
started down on election night
and ended up coming back up and winning
their races
perhaps that's why some of you are
seated in this room today
but imagine if you were behind and the
results start coming in
and as you started pulling ahead your
opponent said
that's not fair stop the count while i'm
still ahead
that's what donald trump did
but that's not how america works
here every vote counts
you don't just stop counting when one
person is ahead
we count every vote
and let's be clear president trump knew
that you can't just stop counting votes
but he wanted to inflame his base there
was a purpose behind this
to truly make them believe that counting
votes would result in a stolen
rigged election he said at 12 49 a.m on
election night quote
they're trying to steal the election we
will never
let them do it
a little over an hour later at roughly 2
30 in the morning
before all the votes or even close to
being counted hope they have video he
goes even further
and actually declares victory here it is
take a look this is a fraud on the
american public
this is an embarrassment to our country
we were getting ready to win this
election
frankly we did win this election
frankly we did win what a clown
rather than calmly saying let's count
the votes
if there's legal issues oh and a big
thank you to uh
molina destiny bonnell ii for hosting us
appreciate that
supporters that he actually won the
election and the whole thing was a fraud
he said that on november 4th and he has
never
recounted that statement since
despite president trump's pressure at
the time
election officials around the country
continued to carry out their duties and
as votes were counted
and his loss became more certain he
riled up his base further
take a look at these tweets
[Music]
on november 5th he tweeted if the
president says don't count votes can you
imagine how
screwed we are quote stop the count
stop the fraud senators
[Music]
this is dangerous
i also want you to remember these tweets
for another reason
because that's what it looks like when
donald trump
wants people to stop doing something
[Music]
and bear in mind this is not the
president saying
to his supporters that somebody stole
your cup of coffee
this is the commander-in-chief telling
his supporters
your election is being stolen and you
must stop
the counting of american votes
and it worked his words became their
actions
his commands led to their actions
take a look at this
the same day as those now remember that
there were people in arizona saying stop
the count
but people in in michigan saying keep
counting
election center in phoenix some of them
carrying rifles
literally trying to intimidate officials
to stop
the count justice president trump that's
a pitchfork
a literal pitchfork arizona secretary of
state katie hobbs
said that protesters were quote causing
disled delay
and disruption and preventing those
employees
from doing their job let's call this
what it was
we're facing a global pandemic workers
were risking their health to ensure the
integrity of our elections
and president trump's supporters were
encircling them
trying to prevent prevent them from
doing their own jobs
this was dangerous it was scary and it
was a blatant act of political
intimidation
in philadelphia that same day
police investigated an alleged plot to
attack the city's pennsylvania
convention center
where votes were being counted police
took at least
one man into custody who was carrying a
weapon
and this happened all over in atlanta
in detroit and in milwaukee his
supporters used armed force
to try to disrupt lawful counting of
votes votes because they
bought into trump's big lie that the
election was stolen
from them president trump's months
of inflaming and inciting his supporters
had worked
they believed it was their duty
to quite literally fight to stop the cow
so they showed up at election centers
across the country to do just that
this is a fraud on the american public
this is an embarrassment to our country
we were getting ready to win this
election
frankly we did win this election
this guy's such an idiot
[Music]
here they want vote counts we were
winning
in all the key locations by a lot
actually
and then our numbers started
miraculously getting whittled away
in secret
[Music]
that's alex jones
right and there it is
they had bought into his big lie
president trump told his supporters over
and over again
nearly every day in dozens of tweets
speeches and rallies
that their most precious right in our
democracy
their voice their vote was being
stripped away
and they had to fight to stop that and
they believed him
and so they fought and you may say
well he didn't know that they'd take up
arms
but when he did know when it was all
over the news
president trump didn't stop
[Music]
as mr swalwell will show after donald
trump lost
he became even more desperate right and
incited his base
even further he urged them
again and again with increasingly
forceful language
to fight to stop the steel and even as
the certification got closer
and he grew even more desperate he gave
them
specific instructions on how
where and when to fight to stop the
steel
he told them to show up on january sixth
and march to the u s capital to stop the
certification of the election results
and he told them to come here and fight
like hell
and they did you will see clearly
that this violent mob that showed up
here on january 6
didn't come out of thin air
president donald john trump incited
this violence that's the truth
[Music]
eric swalwell next i believe
[Music]
this should be interesting
[Music]
mr president distinguished senators
my name is eric swalwell and i represent
california's 15th congressional district
manager castro just told you about
donald trump's lies and acts
before the election but
to paraphrase winston churchill that
wasn't the end of his
efforts that wasn't the beginning of the
end
but perhaps it was the end of the
beginning
right here's what i mean you saw
president trump prime for months
his supporters to believe that if the
election was lost
it only could have been so because it
was rigged
but that took time just like to build a
fire
it doesn't just start with the flames
donald trump
for months and months assembled the
tinder
the kindling threw on logs for fuel
to have his supporters believe that the
only way their victory would be lost
was if it was stolen so that way
president trump was ready if he lost the
election
to light the match right
and on november 7 after all the votes
were counted
president trump did lose by 7
million votes
but for donald trump all was not lost
he had a backup plan instead of
accepting the results
or pursuing legitimate claims he told
his base
more lies he doused
the flames with kerosene
and this wasn't just some random guy at
the neighborhood bar
blowing off steam this was our commander
in chief day after day he told his
supporters
false outlandish lies that the victory
that the election outcome was taken and
it was rigged
and he had absolutely no support for his
claims
doesn't matter that wasn't the point
right he wanted to make his base angrier
and angrier
and to make them angry he was willing to
say anything
on november 15 he states
i concede nothing we have a long way to
go
rigged election
doesn't say why the election is rigged
well he doesn't know
november 17 in a twitter statement
[Music]
dead people voted
[Music]
that's it no evidence
just dead people voted dead people yeah
november 28 twitter statement
we have found many illegal votes stay
tuned
this just wasn't true he never found
illegal votes
he didn't even try to pretend that he
had evidence for that and stay tuned
well that was all about inciting his
base
not about bringing legitimate claims it
was about dramatizing the election
to anger his supporters december 5
you see here he goes after the governors
of arizona
and georgia governors from his own party
claiming that they weren't with him
you see senators he is casting this in
combat terms
right that either you were with him
making sure
that he won the election
or you're fighting against him
these are just a few of the hundreds of
twitter statements
that president trump sent and it wasn't
just twitter statements
as you'll see he was dialing into
meetings holding rallies
appearing on television continuing to
spread the big lie
that his election victory was people
asking me about the democratic approach
so far i think it's very good
remember that they're not going to get
an acquittal but this is very good i
mean sorry they're not going to get a
conviction but it's very good well done
but dead people were requesting ballots
and they were dead for years dead
dead people voting all over the place
the alleged biden margin of victory in
several states is entirely accounted for
by
extraordinarily large midnight vote
dumps you saw that
going up to the sky dumps
just massive dumps do people want me to
address the dead voter thing or just
keep playing the audio you guys let me
know
he said there were votes going up to the
sky
this was never about pursuing legitimate
claims he was saying anything he could
to trigger and anger his base so the
thing all right
to overturn a legitimate election take
it easy
and it worked just as manager castro
showed you president trump's supporters
were taking up arms
to stop the count his message to fight
like steel
fight like hell was having real
consequences
[Music]
in michigan fight like thieves you'll
recall that president trump was
attacking that state
and its officials he continued these
attacks
even after michigan certified his votes
take a look at michigan take a look at
what they did
with respect to counties and then you
get to
detroit and it's like
more votes than people not true
dead people voting all over the place
untrue you know i went almost every
county in michigan almost every district
we should have won that state very
easily we have a similar type of
governor i think but i'll let you know
that in about a week
[Music]
he's literally telling them that there
were more votes in detroit
than people 260 000 people voted in
detroit
there are roughly 500 000 registered
voters
in detroit there are approximately
670 000 people living in the city
so again not true but he needed to make
these outlandish claims
to truly make his supporters believe
that their victory
was stolen from them and it was working
a few days after these clips on december
5 his supporters surrounded
the michigan secretary of state's home i
love the clip show approach secretary
of estate house
and uh the steal
stop the steal stop the steal
stop the steal stop the steal what an
embarrassment
[Music]
stop the steal
[Music]
nine o'clock at night secretary's
family's inside
protesters have surrounded her home
and they're chanting that she's a felon
nice people as we saw when armed
protesters showed up to follow president
trump's direction to stop the steal
this was not the first time that
president trump's supporters used
threats and intimidation nor the last
president trump cannot say i didn't know
what i was inciting
from what manager castro showed and what
i just showed
there was plenty of evidence that his
words had consequences
and if he wanted to stop it he could
stop it
you saw mr castro read statement after
statement from our commander-in-chief
saying stop the count stop the steal
president trump was never shy about
using
his platforms to try and stop something
he could have very easily told his
supporters stop threatening officials
stop going to their homes he did say
it's time for peace
six hours after the riot started
he didn't instead in the face
of escalating violence he incited them
further
the next phase in the certification of
results was the certification on
december 14
of the electoral college votes
the night before president trump
personally issued
14 twitter statements with more false
claims about the election being stolen
please put him in directing his
supporters to make sure that
quote they cannot be certified
here we go he states here
the rhinos the rhinos
that run the state voting apparatus have
caused us the problem of allowing the
democrats to so blatantly cheat
in their attempt to steal the election
which we won overwhelmingly
right we will never give up
in the face of threats to elected
officials
this is his message and he calls them
rhinos
they should call them hippos
hypocritical p.o.s
hippos president trump
to him it was his supporters against
anyone who would not
overturn the election results so that
president trump could win
but on december 14 despite all of
president trump's efforts to stop
the electors cast their votes according
to the will of the american people
and joe biden was certified as having
won 306 electoral college votes
the day after this occurred leader
mcconnell
recognized this stating many of us hope
that the presidential election would
yield a different result
but our system of government has
processes to determine who will be sworn
in on january 20.
the electoral college has spoken
as manager castro said no one here
no one among us wants to lose an
election
sometimes there's a reason to dispute an
election sometimes the count is close
sometimes we ask for a recount or we go
to court
that's entirely appropriate but what
president trump did
was different what president trump did
was the polar opposite of what any of us
would do
if we lost an election not any of us
because once the
ted cruz is in the audience guys there's
rules
we concede we recognize the will
of the american people because we let
the people decide
and that's what all of the courts the
justice department
and the 50 states that have counted the
votes
they said it was time for a peaceful
transition of power because that's what
our constitution
and rule of law demands
president trump he directed
all of the rage that he had incited to
january 6. that was his last chance to
stop
the peaceful transition of power
and that brings us to the attack
manager castro told you the power of the
lie
especially when the lie comes from the
most powerful person in the world
the commander-in-chief it also helps
if you spend millions of dollars to
amplify that lie
you'll see here in mid-december
president trump announced the release of
ads including ones entitled
the evidence is overwhelming fraud
stop the steal yeah but that was just to
raise money 50 million
from his legal defense fund on these ads
to stop the steel and amplify his
message
they were released nationally played in
video ads
online advertising and targeted text
messages
they used the same words and phrases
that president trump had been spreading
for months
that the election was full of fraud to
stop the steel
but now they had a specific purpose
[Music]
how do we know that purpose these ads
were designed to run
all the way up to january 5
and then they stopped
this was purposeful and deliberate
planning to target his base to rally
around that day
and it wasn't just his ads
he continued to use his own platform he
told his supporters who truly believed
their victory had been stolen
and who were ready to fight when where
and how
to stop what he believed was a steal
donald trump would issue a deliberate
call to action
[Music]
and just like in his ads that was action
that action
centered around january 6. there it is
on december 19 at 1 42 in the morning
our commander-in-chief tweeted
big protest in dc on january 6th
be there will be wild
it wasn't wrong we'll be wild
we know why he picked this day it wasn't
random
it was his last chance to stop a
peaceful transition of power
and he gave his supporters plenty of
time to plan
this was the save the date sent out 18
days
before the event on january 6th will be
wide
it wasn't a casual one-off reference or
a single invitation
for the next 18 days donald trump would
make sure to remind them
over and over and over to show up on
january 6th
and he would tell them exactly what he
wanted them to do
on december 26 he tweets if
a democrat presidential candidate had an
election
rigged and stolen with proof of such
acts at a level never seen before
the democrat senators would consider it
an act of war
and fight to the death mitch and the
republicans
do nothing just want to let it pass
no fight
[Music]
he's saying that the republicans are
doing nothing and have no fight
because you are doing your job taking on
the constitutional process of certifying
the electoral college results
and he also suggests president trump
that if this was the reverse
and the democrats had lost it would be
an act of war
i'm sure war and fighter euphorisms
right that's how donald trump prepared
his supporters
for january 6. he even stated again
14 minutes later to make sure his
supporters understood
quote the justice department
and the fbi have done nothing about the
2020
presidential election voter fraud the
biggest
scam all caps in our nation's history
despite overwhelming evidence you have
to call it all you should be ashamed
and then he adds history will remember
never give up see everyone in dc on
january 6th
that phrase history history will
remember
was the only time the first time
donald trump had used it in his
presidency
and he sent this to 70 plus million
twitter followers
the day they needed to show up and be
ready to fight those were the days
on december 27 he reminds them again
don't miss it information to follow
a few days later december 30. all caps
see you in dc this continues all the way
up to january 6.
no coupon code on january 1 he states
the big protest rally in washington
will take place at 11 am
locational details to follow stop the
steal
you'll see that an hour later president
trump
retweeted one of his twitter followers
that follower was kylie cremer
executive director of women for america
first
the group organizing the january 6 rally
and the creator of the facebook group
stop the steal kremmer tweeted
quote the cavalry is coming mister guys
the terms cavalry
war fight fight to the death these are
euphemisms only for supporters to rsvp
i'm also going to make it clear what the
message was
stop the steel and what did president
trump say
in response to hearing that the cavalry
was coming
[Music]
a great honor he wrote back
this wasn't just a single tweet
he and his organizers would do this over
and over repeatedly
on january 3 another supporter tweets we
have been marching all around the
country for you mr president
now we will bring it to dc on january 6
and proudly stand beside you thank you
for fighting for us
when president trump reposted her tweet
she wrote back
best day ever thank you for the retweet
it has been an honor to stand up and
fight for you in our nation we will be
standing strong on january 6th in dc
with you
we are bringing the cavalry mr president
we are bringing the cavalry
that was the consistent message
this was not just any old protest
president trump was inciting something
historic
the cavalry was coming
and he was organized
[Music]
in her post
miss lawrence tagged kylie cremer the
organizer of the event
whose post we just saw president trump
retweet
again you see this is all connected
[Music]
i want to show you all of the twitter
statements and there are a lot
but here's one more
president trump retweeted another of
miss kremmer's posts which had all the
details of january 6. guys by the way
i'm kidding that they're euphemisms
i'm i'm pretending to be like a
right-wing clown or one of trump's
lawyers i
i don't these weren't euphemisms i know
people in the chat seem to be i'm just
kidding i don't i'm
i'm not really saying these are
euphemisms historic day
[Music]
before congress i prosecuted violent
crimes in california
as an alameda county deputy district
attorney
and when you investigate and prosecute
violent crimes you have to distinguish
was this a heat of passion crime or was
it something
more deliberate planned premeditated
the evidence here on this count is
overwhelming
president trump's conduct leading up to
january 6
was deliberate planned and premeditated
this was not one speech not one tweet
it was dozens in rapid succession with
the specific details
he was acting as part of the host
committee
in fact when he had assembled his
inflamed mob in
dc he warned us that he knew
what was coming
[Music]
this was president trump's statement the
night before
the attack i should say this was one of
his dozens of statements on twitter
in the hours leading up to the attack
[Music]
i hope the democrats and even more
importantly the weak
and ineffective rhinos section of the
republican party
are looking at the thousands of people
pouring into dc
they won't stand for a landslide victory
to be stolen at
senate majority leader john cornyn
senator john thune
thousands of people pouring into dc who
won't stand for the land side election
to be stolen
it's all right there and he tags
senators
to pressure you for people wondering
rhino is republican in name only it's
sort of like a way to say a fake
republican
whom you'll see that the fbi had warned
were armed and targeting the capital
won't stand for us certifying the
results of the election
this was never about one's speech
he built this mob over many months with
repeated messaging
until they believed that they had been
robbed of their vote
and they would do anything to stop the
certification
he made the he made them believe that
their victory was stolen
and incited them so he could use them to
steal the election
for himself
this election was rigged this is tyranny
against the people of the united states
and we are not standing for it
anymore if we don't root out the fraud
the tremendous
and horrible fraud that's taken place in
our 2020 election
we don't have a country anymore the left
lies they cheat and they steal
they are ruthless and they are hell-bent
on getting power and control by any
means necessary that's a stephen hiller
lineup
[Applause]
can't let it happen
[Music]
the democrats are trying to steal the
white house you cannot
let them
can't let it happen never concede fight
he told them in speech after speech
these crowds were ready to fight
this is what president trump was
inciting
he foresaw what was coming and this is
what he
deliberately led to our doorstep on
january 6.
[Music]
i want to be clear during this trial
when we talk about the violent mob
during the attack
we do not mean every american who showed
up at president trump's rally
certain americans came to protest
peacefully
as is their right that is what makes our
country so great
to debate freely openly and peacefully
our differences just like all of you
were attempting to do
in this very room on january 6
but what president trump did was
different
he didn't tell his supporters to fight
or be strong in a casual reference
he repeatedly over months told him to
fight for a specific purpose
he told them their victory was stolen
the election was rigged and their
patriotic duty
was to fight to stop the steel
[Music]
and he repeated this messaging even
after he saw the violence it was
inciting
and when they were primed and angry and
ready to fight
he escalated and channeled their range
with a call to arms
show up on january 6 at the exact time
the votes
of the american people were being
counted and certified and then marched
to the capitol
and fight like hell he told us to
thousands of people who were armed to
the teeth
targeting us and determined to stop the
electoral college count
[Music]
what our commander-in-chief did was
wildly different
from what anyone here in this room did
to raise election concerns
this was a deliberate premeditated
incitement to his base
to attack our capital while the counting
was going on
and it was foreseeable especially to
president trump
who warned us he knew what was coming
right this is what the evidence has
overwhelmingly shown
and will show in this trial and it's
also the truth
wow so there's eric swalwell
president friend of the majority leader
i ask you to
consent the senate recess for a
15-minute break
without objection so ordered
all right the senate will now be in
recess it'll give us a chance to uh jump
in and discuss a few things
so uh very very strong
again first day second day what are we
calling it today it's sort of uh you
know it's it's both
in a sense um just very briefly
i'll talk about the dead voters thing
because that is something that keeps
coming up and it just gets repeated and
a lot of people
sometimes will send me an article and
say look there is this list of like 10
000 supposedly dead voters
um it's this has been researched widely
okay and here's
here's the bottom line with dead voters
many of them aren't really dead in other
words they were alive
just because someone is on a list as
you're dead
you might be alive this happened to me
you guys might remember when i was
featured in a documentary about bullied
gay
teens who had died by suicide and at the
time
i at the time and now um
i'm not gay i wasn't a teen i wasn't
bullied and i was alive so like
sometimes
you just get it wrong okay so some of
the people on the list of dead voters
were alive
plain and simple others were dead but
they didn't vote
they were registered because they
registered when alive
then they died and they didn't vote
so that gets a whole bunch of others off
the list
there were a lot a lot there were some
clerical errors where you know
imagine uh
it wouldn't be david pakman jr and
senior since jewish folks don't do
junior and senior but imagine like you
you know
fred smith senior and fred smith jr fred
smith senior
might be dead fred smith jr votes but
it's counted as fred smith
seniors vote that's a clerical error
it's still only one vote those people
aren't voting twice
so um you know
the dead voters thing is is just an
absolute uh farce and it's not
uh it's it's not real okay uh yes and uh
people are denying that i'm actually
alive i am alive right now
okay let me say there's so many people
were signing up and supporting during
that
i do want to thank combo carl and helen
dear
for signing up via twitch we do have a
little
a little goal here of a hundred 35
website members
and twitch subs it all counts the goal
is a hundred i also want to say thank
you to
uh pat padre i don't know how to say
this it's i believe it's an
irish name padraig i think it's the
irish version of peter
can someone tell me how to pronounce
that please
nobody knows okay
patrick it's not patrick
padrig padraig oh it's patrick it is
patrick like porridge
okay all right uh thank you to pat
patrick doyle
as well as um jess johnson
for signing up at joinpackman.com we
have a coupon code
it's better21 the coupon code is legal
the coupon code is moral the coupon code
is working
and you can use it and then you start to
fill up this bar
and it's a beautiful beautiful thing and
of course your subscription support
the impeachment streams and other
streams let me look at a few super chats
i want to send a big thank you to a user
named
shiak who sent a 100
super super chat with the message david
i am so thankful for all your effort
appreciate it shiok very much appreciate
it um
let's see here zachary says i remember
that did you find out how you made that
list yeah apparently i
covered i covered a story about people
who were bullied
and somehow i ended up on the
documentary as someone who was bullied
and died by suicide
logan asks whether the evidence is
designed to convince senate members or
if it's just discourse
rand paul seems to want to doodle his
notebook yeah i mean
as i've said before i don't believe you
there's any path to 17 republicans
voting to convict
i just am not aware of any path towards
it
charles variations sends a 25 super chat
and says wanted someone to go back in
time with me this is not a joke bring
your own weapons you will get paid after
we get back
safety not guaranteed i have done this
only once before
is that a calvin and hobbes reference i
don't know why i
i feel like um
like that's a calvin and hobbes
reference
do we know is that what that is
wait no no no that's not no it's not
calvin and hobbes
where is that line from i recognize that
line
it's a dinosaur meme okay all right why
do senators not vote in secret uh
because that's not the way the rules are
established they could decide
that it's a secret ballot they could
absolutely do that
uh but it doesn't appear as though there
is interest in doing that at this point
in time
uh okay let me do oh oh oh
i finally have some um
unban requests that i can do
okay i want you guys to help me i'm
gonna there there's people who have been
banned on twitch remember twitch mods
do not adjudicate any unban requests i'm
gonna do all of them myself okay let's
just go through and you guys can tell me
whether some of these people should be
unbanned here's one user
whose communications on the
uh on the channel so far
have included let's take a look here
kaylee is hot i love her hot and smart
kaylee is bae
kaylee is hot four more years of kaylee
kaylee sure is purdy she's purdy
she's very purty hang traders garbage
can man
and then they were banned and they want
to be unbanned what do people think
stay banned unbanned
it doesn't actually sound that bad i
think i'm gonna unban them
i'm gonna unban that person okay send
unbanned decision
yeah that doesn't seem i think i'm okay
with that person being unbanned all
right let's see what else
we've got from the standpoint of bans um
here's another user
let's see this person talking about me
isn't this the same dude that was wrong
af election night 2016.
yeah that's true remember when david
said there was no way trump could win in
2016. that's fine that's just a critique
david stfu david stfu stfu david
yeah i mean you know that
that's probably a stay banned for right
now
uh let's see what else we've got here
we're looking at people who have been
banned and want to be
unbanned let's see what we've got here
here's another one
saki's husband brother is a high up at a
hedge fund destiny loses again
institutional investors do that destiny
is literally saying institutional
investors can come together
density destiny density bipartisan
f chuck schumer david is just as fake as
fate gets
i'm going to unban i don't think that's
that bad i i'm okay with that see
sometimes you just have to ban them in
the moment like it's okay that some of
these people are getting banned in the
moment because you just have to stop
them
in at that time and then you know they
can be unbanned later
here's another one let's see
harassing a particular user directing
messages to a user saying let's get it
shall we debate let's debate
just because i support most of trump's
actions means i'm a confederate
swalwell my ass effing spy that's not
true
first of all don't recall if you could
do a show me please
uh i think i'm gonna keep this person
it just seems very bad faith
um all right let's go to the next one
we've just got one more for people who
hate this
it's almost over biden stole the
election
biden cheated as and there is proof
biden and hunter are frauds
still are frauds yeah that's a ban we're
just not gonna
allow people who are just and that was
all in five minutes
so we're definitely that's staying
banned and then here
is the last one um
this was someone who was banned oh this
person was only banned eight minutes ago
okay
trump is still my president joe biden is
responsible for what happened at the
capitol
trump 2024 we can't handle where a bun
mods can't handle wear a bunch of
beta cucks simps biden leg lickers
then they were banned and then their
ban appeal message was fu
simps chuds racist so that one is a stab
that's staying banned for sure
that's a perma that's perma
okay good all right so we did it i think
that that's pretty interesting i
appreciate people who stayed with me for
that um
unfortunately i don't believe that
youtube has
a um an unban request
mechanism but twitch does and i think i
i like that i don't know
i mean i think you guys can see that the
difference between
just a temporary cool off and
an absolute undeniable perma-ban
is pretty um is pretty clear
it's pretty clear i don't think there's
any there's any doubt between those
okay very good i want to say some
really exciting thank yous to people who
just signed up at joinpackman.com we are
in a brief break and then the senate
will resume
stanley minarik just signed up at
jointpakman.com
jessica owens just signed up thanks
jessica
appreciate that sandy harris is a new
member at joinpackman.com
kathy denning just signed up thanks
kathy
uh mark ramsdell is a new member at
joinedpakman.com so is katherine dahl
thank you catherine oh hold on i
mentioned stanley minarik already
unless stanley got a second membership
no i don't think so and then
aluca lindstrom also signing up
at joinpackman.com very much appreciate
that that's
five which puts us at 40 and then also
big thanks on twitch to
nature boy don't message me shapa
cemenki snow crow
andre bavaria perkisizing
rhys martin denklout and ez4 heinz
that is 10 additional
twitch subs thanks very much guys i do
appreciate that
uh this is earlier guys the senate is in
recess uh we are standing by it was
going to be
a 15 minute recess and expecting them to
come back very shortly we're not missing
anything this was all
earlier all earlier okay
um all right let's see
what else do we have uh oh
i do have some super chats i did want to
read okay cnn says new evidence coming
up
safety not guaranteed is a 2012 american
rom-com
film rest in peace bullied gay teen
pacman your spirit
lives in this very believable hologram
god bless technology and god bless
america
wow plenty of the republicans would vote
to convict if it were a secret ballot
and it should be
i completely agree
last 2g verdict mcauli
mcconnell avoiding perot repeat i don't
know what that means
shouldn't republicans vote to impeach
because if not he may run again
either forcing himself to be their
candidate or risk splitting the vote
yeah there's there's a degree to which
you would say hey if the republican
party really wants to rid itself of
donald trump they should actually
uh bar him from holding office in the
future i i think that that you're
thinking too far ahead they don't think
that far ahead
andrew says swalwell specified that the
efforts of the president to overturn the
election
are well beyond any efforts of anyone in
the senate was he maybe giving them an
out remove the self-preservation element
yeah i found it interesting for him to
mention that in particular because
it's it's not obviously the case i think
there are many many republicans who who
would gladly have done what trump did
they just didn't think it would work i
don't know if trump even believed it
would work it may have been posturing
from trump
david love listening to you as i work
maybe tell people not to type the quote
marks in better 21.
people may be typing in the quote marks
and it's not working
that's an interesting question do you
guys think we often see how there's a
coupon code above my head there better21
and the code is in quotes
do you guys think that the quotes are
confusing
should i get rid of the quotes do you
think some people are literally typing
in the quotes and that's why it's not
working
all right hold on let me remove the
quotes i can do that
let me just do a little javascript
modification here
let's see if that works oh but then it's
not blue
the quotes make it blue
like what we gain in clarity from
removing the quotes do we lose
because the quote the code is not in
blue anymore
i have no ability to make it uh i have i
have no ability to
make it blue any other way add a css
style
i don't know how to do that yeah i
didn't write the c
the javascript guys i just know how to
edit it
bold tag let's see if the bold tag works
i'm not really trying to do you know
programming on stream here let me see if
the bold tag works
it makes it bold but it's barely
noticeable
how can i make it blue
is there a code for blue a simple code
b style equals color blue
oh wow this is great can you guys
believe this
okay let's code on stream who was it it
was dave rubin that said learn to code
uh hold on it scrolled so far past that
i can't even see it
okay style equals
color blue
whoa oh my god that did not work it now
it's the entire thing we're gonna have
to get rid of that
all right i'm gonna deal with this off
stream guys we'll just leave it as bold
and low quotes so far uh uh bold and no
quotes for the time being
i think i also need to pick a particular
hue
italic maybe all right guys we're
getting away from that i'm getting away
from twitch now because
the things people are saying i know
people are just messing with me uh we're
standing by for the return of the senate
thanks to aaron kane for signing up at
joinpackman.com very much appreciate
that erin
um i saw someone else signed up let me
see if i can get back to that
we're not missing anything guys this was
earlier
this was earlier okay
you are missing nothing air thanks to
aaron kane
kaylee marcus also grabbed a membership
at
a joinedpakman.com happening at once
here big thank you to sean hansen
for signing up at joinedpakman.com and
tony lymon also for signing up
appreciate that thank you very much
um a lot of other messages coming in
david doesn't a secret ballot only
require a simple majority why couldn't
democrats do it
i believe it does and i read a piece
recently about why
they're not going to do it and it was it
was pretty convincing
um quotes should be white or replace
them with blue hearts
should trump hire mike pillow to defend
him
yeah i would like to see that what do
you think of the democrats argument so
far i think it's very good
now listen we know what the republican
uh with what trump's lawyers are going
to say
trump's lawyers are going to come in and
they're going to say when trump said
fight he didn't mean
physical violence he meant you know a
figurative fight
uh these were euphemisms these were
metaphors
metaphorical metaphors um
that's what they're going to do they're
going to say it's vague it's not
specific
so on and so forth so i you know i think
it's the right
they're doing the right thing but if 50
plus kamala voted to make it a secret
ballot it would only take 20 republicans
to say they want it public for it to be
a required public vote that's the
explanation that's right 20 republicans
could reverse it yep
my guess is trump made a threat to
mccarthy during his visit forced the gop
to acquit or trump will start his own
party to split the gop
i don't think there's any evidence for
that but it's an interesting idea merely
to speculate about
um oh okafor says hey david glad to hear
from you again did you hear trump is
under criminal investigation in georgia
what are your thoughts
yeah i'm i'm covering that tomorrow i
don't have thoughts yet i've not read
the details yet
but i'm aware that it happened and i
will
um absolutely talk about that on the
show tomorrow
people asking what's going on with my
bitcoin nothing i'm just holding
uh on january 1st i did sell
15 of my bitcoin and i wish i hadn't i
was just locking in some gains obviously
had i held i would have done much better
this is why i don't
pretend to know what i'm doing i just
i don't even pretend to know what i'm
doing i should have just held it all
some folks saying trump only hires the
best lawyers i assume that that's satire
do you believe if the republicans had
the majority in the house on one sixth
they would have actually flipped the
election
um no i don't think so
is there a chance the senate vote will
will be anonymous no we've just we've
been discussing that
oh uh so by the way i don't know how
many of you guys
were looking at any news articles this
morning
but uh yesterday when bruce castor
was uh ranting and raving about
his views on pre-revolutionary british
law
and his opinion about senators and which
vinyl records he liked and stuff like
that i was saying this is so bad
i wonder if he even makes it to tomorrow
and we now have multiple reports that
indeed donald trump was screaming and
was furious
and uh yeah it was not a joke
all right we've got a little more code
here let's see if we can make
better 21 make a little more sense
nope that did not work
too bad all right no problem no
no rush guys we've got hours here during
which we'll be dealing with all of this
stuff
can i do more unban requests there
aren't any that i'm aware of
no i did all of them uh
yeah there's no more maybe tomorrow
maybe tomorrow
okay i need an ending tag
i'm probably not closing the tag
okay we're gonna deal with that later
guys quick merch idea for free
david pakman show shirts with can you
imagine
would certainly buy that it's not a bad
idea not a bad idea what will the 2024
republican debates look like if trump
can run standing next to the person
ted that didn't vote to convict burying
themselves now
i i honestly i don't know how many
people will run against trump if trump
is a 2024 candidate i don't think
trump's running in 2024 i think trump
will forget about it he'll be 78
and um 78 or 79 he'll be
i i just don't think he's going to do it
okay
are you go are you into going on round
tables uh
you should hit up dylan burns would be
fun seeing you no i just don't have time
i just don't have you know there's this
there's this thing now
i know many of you know it because i
know people people like the uh
some of these i get invited all the time
to like two hour three hour four hour
things
i i i just don't have time you know it's
like i'm doing my show
managing the team um
[Music]
doing streams you know i have things i
want to read i i want time off
i can't appear on a three-hour round
table it just
i i'm just too busy for it at this point
in time will trump's lawyers start
screaming about lawyer lawsuits
probably not this time probably not this
time i don't expect that to happen
should i hire a pre-revolutionary lawyer
to overturn my dui yeah why not
why not those duis can be pretty
stubborn things
thanks to gregory hutto miko 7
linebook al cinicinade
young hegel jules's cools
and many others i would appear on the
austin show
yeah anytime he wants me on schedule
permitting i would do it
it's too explosive not to do but i do
appreciate the seven folks who just uh
signed up via twitch
also a few other members to thank this
is the best time to do it because
it's when i have time to actually thank
people nushin
haravi just signed up at joinpackman.com
matt bach just signed up
big thank you to philip shapiro for the
membership at joinedpakman.com
relic has signed up
and lastly mary buchanan i love it when
i just get a simple name that i know i'm
saying correctly
mary buchanan also signing up at
joinpackman.com
you are not missing anything we are
standing by
for uh the resumption of
day two of donald trump's second
impeachment
uh when they come back i am going to
step away for a bit
work on tomorrow's program by popular
demand we're just running the stream all
day we're continuing to run it uh people
wanted it to just go go so we're gonna
do it
and i will be back a little bit later i
may also even try to pick up what i need
to get
super chat set up on screen my second
monitor and all of that stuff i want uh
we of course want
all the best all the best stream
elements on screen for everybody
uh
oh i pronounced buchanan wrong it's buck
anon
oh my god that's horrible
uh invite mary l trump as a guest i
would love to have her
i would love to have her uh she's
welcome absolutely anytime
for republicans to get the presidential
nomination in 24
trying to get the republican nomination
in 2024 will it end up being solely
about who trump loves most
it's too early to say a lot can happen
in the next four years we don't know how
strong
trumpian influence will be in the gop
primary four years from now is
it anybody pretending to know we're just
guessing
david i've been watching this crazy
journey on your channel thanks man
pleasure can we stop using the word
verbiage and start using the real word
verbiage i wish we could yeah that i
would like that and also it's pundit not
pundant
pundit i hear pundit very often it's bad
it's not a word my friend
mr ash thank you mr president um
my colleagues madeline dean and ted lou
will now detail
former president trump's increasingly
desperate attempts to stop the steal
okay i'll be back soon guys stand by
stand back and stand by
mr president
esteemed members of the senate it is my
solemn
honor to be before you today i am
madeline dean
congresswoman from the 4th congressional
district of pennsylvania
i'm a lawyer i'm a former professor of
writing
i'm a sister i'm a wife i'm a mother
i'm a grandmother to three with fourth
on her way
i'm a person of faith and i'm an
american
along with manager lou i will present
the actions of a desperate president
and we will present evidence today of a
class of public servants
who standing up to enormous pressure
from the president of the united states
did the right thing and upheld their
oaths
my colleagues just presented evidence of
a president trump's
months-long efforts to incite his base
leading them to believe the election was
stolen
that they needed to fight like hell to
stop the steel on
january the 6th these weren't president
trump's only efforts to overturn the
results
manager lou and i will present evidence
of president trump's relentless
escalating campaigns to fabricate an
election victory
by ignoring adverse court rulings
pressuring and threatening election
officials attacking
senators and members of congress
pressuring the justice department and
finally bullying his own vice president
president trump and his allies filed
62 separate lawsuits in federal courts
across more than half a dozen states
and the district of columbia including
pennsylvania
my home state as well as arizona
georgia michigan minnesota nevada
and wisconsin of the 62 post-election
legal challenges
he lost 61. only one was successful
and that case involved ballot curing in
pennsylvania
and had no impact on president biden's
80 555 vote victory
in our commonwealth to be clear
not a single court not a single judge
agreed that the election results were
invalid
or should be invalidated instead
court after court reviewing these
challenges said these cases were quote
not credible without merit
based on nothing but speculation
and flat out wrong the judiciary
resoundingly rejected trump's fraud
allegations
and upheld the election results
but it was more than that the courts
said these cases were different
they were dangerous to our democracy for
example
in an opinion by united states district
court judge matthew brann
from pennsylvania he said and i quote
this court has been presented with
strained legal arguments without merit
and speculative accusations in the
united states
of america this cannot justify the
disenfranchisement
of a single voter let alone all the
voters of its sixth most populated state
our people and laws and institutions
demand
more because this court has no authority
to take away the right
to vote of even a single person let
alone millions of citizens
it cannot grant plaintiff's requested
relief
that decision by judge braun was
affirmed on appeal by judge stefanos
bevis a trump appointee who agreed
and wrote and i quote the campaign's
claims have no merit the number of
ballots it specifically challenges is
far smaller than the roughly 81 000
vote margin of victory and it never
claims fraud
or that any of the votes were cast by
illegal
voters plus tossing out millions of
mail-in ballots would be drastic
and unprecedented disenfranchising a
huge swath of the electorate
and upsetting all down ballot races
end quote similarly
as judge linda parker of the eastern
district of michigan
framed it she said stunning in its scope
and breathtaking in its reach if granted
the relief would disenfranchise
the votes of more than 5.5
million michigan citizens who with
dignity
and hope and a promise of a vote
participated in the 2020 general
election
donald trump told his supporters they
are stealing the election
they took away your vote it's rigged
that was not true according to judge
after judge the truth was exactly the
opposite
trump was not suing to ensure election
integrity
he was pursuing lawsuits that would in
effect strip away american votes
so that he could win in other words
donald trump was asking the judiciary to
take away
votes from americans so that he
could steal the election for himself
then after losing in all the courts
trump turned to another tactic
pressuring and threatening election
officials you saw what happened in
michigan
after trump attacked the state and its
election officials
his supporters surrounded the secretary
of state's home
as you saw in the earlier slide chanting
calling her a felon on november 17th the
board of canvassers
for wayne county michigan home to
detroit unanimously certified the
election results for biden
that same night after their vote to
certify the results
trump called the two rep republican
members of that
board pressuring them to change their
minds
the call worked the next day both monica
palmer
and william hartman the republican board
members
attempted to rescind their vote to
certify michigan's election results
but they simply couldn't president trump
didn't stop there
he then contacted majority leader of the
michigan senate
mike shirkey and the speaker of the
michigan house lee
chatfield to lobby them to overturn
michigan's results
trump invited mr chatfield and mr
shirkey to washington to meet with him
at the white house
where the president lobbied them further
let's be clear donald trump was calling
officials
hosting them at the white house urging
them to defy the voters in their state
and instead award votes to trump the
officials held strong
and so trump moved on to a different
state my home state of pennsylvania
i am certain my senators casey and
senator toomey
remember what happened there in early
december as he did in michigan
he began calling election officials
including my former colleagues in the
pennsylvania legislature
republicans majority leader kim ward and
speaker of the house
brian cutler majority leader ward said
the president called her to quote
declare there was a fraud in the voting
end quote
then on november 25th president trump
phoned into a republican state
senate policy hearing trying to convince
the republican legislators
senators and house members there had
been a fraud in the vote
he even had his lawyer hold a phone up
to the microphone in that hearing room
so the committee could hear him here is
what he said
[Music]
we can't let that happen we can't let it
happen for our country
and this election has to be turned
around because
we won pennsylvania by a lot and we won
all of these
swing states by a lot
this was a gathering i've attended many
i have to tell you as a former state
legislator a lot of policy hearings
i have to say with some confidence that
was likely the first time
a president of the united states of
america called into a state legislative
policy hearing
and remember here is the president
saying he won
pennsylvania and pennsylvania had been
certified
that biden had won by more than 80 000
votes
less than a week after calling into that
meeting
he invited multiple republican members
of the pennsylvania legislature
to the white house the same scheme he
had used on the michigan legislators
it didn't work with those public
servants either
think about it the president of the
united states
was calling public officials calling
from the white house
inviting them into the oval office
telling them to disenfranchise voters of
their state
telling them to overturn the will of the
american people
also he could take the election for
himself
and then in georgia a state trump had
counted on for victory
his conduct was perhaps the most
egregious
on november 11th republican secretary of
state brad raffensberger confirmed
that he believed ballots were act
accurately
counted for biden trump went on a
relentless attack
here are just a few examples in all
trump tweeted at raffensberger 17 times
in the coming week
i'll show you just a few calling him a
disaster
obstinate not having a clue being played
for a fool
and being a so-called republican all
because raffensberger was doing his job
ensuring the integrity of our elections
and these attacks had consequences mr
raffensberger and his family received
death threats
quote your husband deserves to face a
firing squad
you better not botch this recount your
life depends upon it
the raffensberger should be put on trial
for treason and face execution
just some of the threats they received
after these death threats on november
25th mr raffensberger
wrote an op-ed where he said my
family voted for trump donated to him
and are now being thrown under the bus
by him
[Music]
but he also noted elections are the
bedrock of our democracy
they need to be run fairly and perhaps
more importantly
impartially that's not partisan
that's just american it's important to
remember
that this wasn't just a random attack
trump wasn't just criticizing a
politician over policy
we're saying he didn't agree donald
trump was savagely attacking a secretary
of state because the official did his
job
and certified the state according to how
the people in that state voted
donald trump was trying to undermine our
elections by taking votes away from the
american people
so that he could remain president and he
was willing to blame and betray
anyone anyone even his own supporters
if they got in the way remember senators
those threats were to mr raffensberger's
family
so some may say trump didn't know his
attacks against mr raffensberger would
result in death threats
except that all of this was very public
the secretary published his op-ed in usa
today
and major networks including fox covered
the threats against the raffensburger
what did trump do did he stop
did he say no no supporters that isn't
what i meant
no he doubled down let's see the
evidence
this was a massive fraud this should
never take place in this country we're
like a third world country
look at look at georgia but i understand
the secretary of state
who is really he's an enemy of the
people
the secretary of state and whether he's
republican or not
this man what he's done this character
in georgia who's a disaster
let that sink in a republican
public servant doing his job whose
family had just received death threats
and the president of the united states
labeled him
an enemy of the people
[Music]
and that's why this is different because
this was not just
one attack or one comment this was
attack
after attack in the face of clear
threats of violence
and on december 1st another official
gabriel sterling
a republican who voted for trump made
this point
and appealed directly to our president
to stop his dangerous
conduct mr president
it looks like you likely lost the state
of georgia we're investigating there's
always a possibility i get it you have
the rights to go through the course
what you don't have the ability to do
and you need to step up and say this
is stop inspiring people to commit
potential acts of violence
someone's going to get hurt someone's
going to get shot someone's going to get
killed
[Music]
mr sterling put this perfectly in this
country we can
appropriately challenge a close count
or go to the courts or disagree with
others
or make bold statements but what trump
was doing was different
someone's going to get hurt someone's
going to get
shot someone's going to get killed
mr sterling saw what trump's conduct was
fomenting
he warned him on live tv that violence
was already happening
and that more violence was foreseeable
and inevitable
sterling's pleas were played over and
over on
every network rather than heed that
warning
trump escalated again in early december
trump called
brian kemp the governor of georgia and
pressured him to hold a special
session of the state legislature to
overturn the election
results and to appoint electors who
would vote for trump
a few weeks later on december twenty
third trump called the chief
investigator
for the fl for the georgia bureau of
investigations
who was conducting an audit an audit of
the signature matching procedures for
absentee ballots
trump urged him find the fraud
and claim the official would be a
national hero if he did
let's call this what it is he was asking
the official to say there was evidence
of fraud
when there wasn't any the official
refused and the investigation was
completed
and on december 29th raffensberger
announced that the audit found
quote no fraudulent absentee ballots
with a 99 percent
confidence level
on january 3rd trump tweeted about a
call he had with
a georgian georgia election official the
day before
he said and i quote i spoke to secretary
of state brad rappensberger yesterday
about fulton county
and voter fraud in georgia he was
unwilling or
unable to answer questions such as the
ballots under the table scam
ballot destruction out-of-state voters
dead voters and more
he has no clue on january the 5th the
washington post released a recording of
that call
which had occurred on january 2nd
remember just four days before the
attack on the capitol
here is what president trump said it's
more illegal for you than it is for them
because you know what they did and
you're not reporting it that's a you
know that's a
criminal that's a criminal offense and
and you know you can't let that happen
that's that's a big risk
to you and to riot your lawyers that's a
big risk
[Music]
let's be clear this is the president of
the united states telling a secretary of
state
that if he does not find votes he will
face
criminal penalties
and not just any number of votes donald
trump was asking the secretary of state
to somehow
find the exact number of votes donald
trump lost the state by
remember president biden won georgia by
11
779 votes
in his own words trump said all i want
to do is this
i just want to find eleven thousand
seven hundred 780 votes
he wanted the secretary of state to
somehow find the precise number plus one
so that he could win here's what he said
so look
all i want to do is this i just want to
find
[Music]
11 780
votes which is one more that we have
he says it right there the president of
the united states
telling a public official to manufacture
the exact
votes needed so he can win
senators we must not become numb to this
trump did this across state after state
so often
so loudly so publicly
public officials like you and me receive
death threats and calls threatening
criminal penalties
all because trump wanted to remain in
power
these public officials exercised great
political
and personal courage in the face of
unprecedented pressure
from a president of the united states
senators ours is a dialogue with history
a conversation with the past with a hope
for the future
senators i thank you today to for your
kind
attention
[Music]
good afternoon i'm congressman ted lieu
my colleague congresswoman dean went
through president trump's efforts to
overturn the election through the courts
and when that started failing his deeply
disturbing attacks on state and local
officials
i'm going to walk through president
trump's extraordinary
efforts remaining until january 6 when
he tried again to overturn
the election i first want to highlight
represents question to all of you today
is this
america like all of you
i love this country i am an immigrant
my parents came to ohio and we started
off living in the basement
of a person's home we were poor
and they went to flea market to sell
gifts to make ends meet
over many years they built a small
business open six gift stores and
achieved the american dream
it's one reason i joined the united
states air force on active duty
i believe america is an exceptional
country
i was trained as a prosecutor at maxwell
air force base in alabama
and i remain in the reserves because
we're the greatest country in the world
but how did our exceptional country get
to the point
where a violent mob attacked our capital
murdering a police officer assaulting
over 140 other officers
how do you get to the point where
rioters desecrated
defiled and dishonored your senate
chamber
where the very place in which you sit
became a crime
scene and where national guard troops
still patrol
outside wearing body armor i'll
show you how we got here president
donald j trump ran out of
non-violent options to maintain power
after his efforts in the courts and
threatening officials failed
he turned to privately and publicly
attacking members of his own
party in the house and in the senate
he would publicly bait senators naming
them
in social media for example on december
18th
president trump named at senate majority
leader and republican senators telling
them they have to get tougher
or they won't have a republican party
anymore
we won the presidential election by a
lot fight for it
don't let them take it away president
trump was suggesting
members of this senate that if they
didn't help him try to overturn the
election
there would be consequences on december
24th
president trump wrote i saved at least
eight republican senators
including mitch from losing in the last
rigged
for president election now they almost
all
sit back and watch me fight against a
crooked
and vicious foe the radical left
democrats
i will and in all capital letters he
wrote
never forget exclamation point
president trump was telling you that you
owe him
that if you don't help him fight over
the results he will never forget and
that there will be consequences
these are threats just like the threats
he made to state and local officials
and it continued on december 29th
president trump tweeted can you imagine
the republican store presidential
election from the democrats how hell
would break out
republican leadership only wants a path
of least resistance
our leaders not me of course
are pathetic they only know how to lose
p.s i got many senators and congressmen
and congresswoman elected
i do believe they forgot
president trump targeted senators and
members of congress on social media
calling them pathetic for letting
election get
quote stolen from them
on january 4th two days before the
attack
president trump tweeted the surrender
caucus within the republican party
will go down in infamy as weak and
ineffective guardians
of our nation who are willing to accept
their certification
of fraudulent presidential numbers
now he's mocking some republican members
as the surrender caucus
calling them weak and ineffective
guardians of our nation
because they would not pretend that he
had won when in fact he had
not and then the very day before the
attack
president trump's threats grew even more
heated and specific
towards republicans that he considered
to be part of that surrender caucus
now we've shown you this tweet before
but i want to draw your attention how
the president was not just inciting his
base but how
he was also calling out specific senate
republicans at the end
of this tweet this is a specific warning
to anyone who won't help him overturn
the results
anyone who was against the president
became an enemy
and let me be very clear the president
wasn't just coming
for one or two people or democrats like
me
he was coming for you for democratic and
republican
senators he was coming for all of us
just as the mob did at his direction
in addition to going after senators and
members of congress president trump also
pressured
our justice department to investigate
the false claims that the election was
stolen
at the presence direction attorney
general william barr
a loyal member of the president's
cabinet authorized federal prosecutors
to pursue
substantial allegations of voting and
vote tabulation
irregularities bill barr pursuing these
allegations sparked
an outcry 16 assistant u.s attorneys in
the trump administration
urged attorney general to cease
investigations because they had not seen
evidence of any substantial anomalies
that means they did not find any
evidence of real fraud
a transgender board pursued the
investigations anyways
and after his investigation this is what
he found
quote we have not seen fraud on a scale
that could have affected a different
outcome
in the election two weeks later
on december 14th the electors voted to
give joe biden
306 electoral votes and ensured his
victory
the following day bill barr resigned
attorney general boar had lawyerly
served president trump
he had never publicly come out against
the president
but for bill barr making up election
fraud claims
and saying the election was stolen was a
bridge too
far billboard made clear that attempted
overturning election results crossed a
line
according to a news report bill barr the
highest law official
enforcement official in the land told
president donald trump
to his face that his theories of
election fraud
were quote [ __ ]
unquote when bill barr resigned
his former deputy jeff rosen took his
place
president trump initially tweeted about
mr rosen that he was an outstanding
person
when he announced that he would become
acting attorney general
but when rosen took over president trump
put the same pressure on him
that he had done with state officials
members of congress u.s senators
and his former attorney general
president trump reportedly summoned
acting attorney general rosen to the
oval office
the next day and pressured rosen to
appoint special counsels
to keep investigating their election
including
unfounded accusations of widespread
voter fraud
and also to investigate dominion the
voting machines firm
according to reports mr rosen refused
he maintained that he would make
decisions based on the facts in the law
and reminded president trump what he had
already been told by attorney general
bill barr
that the department had already
investigated and quote
found no evidence of widespread fraud
but president trump refused to follow
the facts in the law
so the president turned to someone he
knew would do his bidding
he turned to jeffrey clark another
justice department lawyer
who had allegedly expressed support for
using the department of justice
to investigate the election results
shortly after
acting attorney general rosen followed
his duty and the law to reopen
to refuse to reopen investigations
president trump
intended to replace mr rosen with mr
clark who could then try to stop
congress from certifying the electoral
college results
according to reports white house counsel
pat cipolloni advised president trump
not to fire acting attorney general
rosen
department officials had also threatened
to resign in mass
if he had fired rosen president trump's
actions
time and time again made clear that he
would do anything
and pressure anyone if it meant
overturning the election results
we watched president trump use any means
necessary
to pursue this aim feverishly grasping
for straws
and retaining his hold on their
presidency
but all his efforts prior to january 6
kept
failing and finally in his desperation
he turned on his
own vice president
he pressured mike pence to violate his
constitutional oath and to refuse to
certify the oath
president trump had decided that vice
president pence
who presided over the certification
could somehow stop it
as pence later confirm the vice
president does not have that power in
the constitution
and president trump never tried to
explain why he thought the vice
president could block
the certification of the election
results he just began relentlessly
attacking
the vice president publicly
president trump attacked pence on social
media and at rallies
getting his supporters to believe that
mike pence could stop this certification
on january 6.
here's where president trump said in
georgia on january 4th
and i hope mike pence comes through for
us i have to tell you
i hope that our great vice president
our great vice president comes through
for us he's a great guy
of course if he doesn't come through i
won't like him quite as much
[Music]
behind closed doors president trump
applied significant pressure to his
second in command
multiple reports confirmed that
president trump used his personal
attorneys and other officials
to pressure the vice president trump
reportedly told almost anyone who called
him
to also call the vice president
according reports
when mike pence was in the oval office
president trump would call people to try
to get them to convince the vice
president
to help him and president trump kept
repeating the myth
that pence could stop the certification
to his base to anger them
hoping to intimidate mike pence
on the morning of the rally on january 6
president trump tweeted all mike pence
has to do is send them back to the
states
and all caps he wrote and we win
do what mike this is a time for extreme
courage
president trump later went on to attack
pence nearly a dozen times
in his speech at the save america march
privately in person before pence headed
to oversee the joint session on january
6th
president trump again threatened pence
you can either go down in history as a
patriot mr trump told him
according to two people briefed on the
conversation
or you can go down in history as a [ __ ]
[Music]
as a veteran i find it deeply
dishonorable
that our former president and
commander-in-chief equated patriotism
with violating the constitution and
overturning the election
you will see and hear the consequences
of president trump's repeated attacks on
the vice president
the chance of traitor and the chance of
haying mike pence
thankfully vice president pence stood
his ground
like our other brave officials stood
their ground
he refused their president and fulfilled
his duty on january 6
even after the capital was attacked even
after he was personally targeted even
after his family was targeted
vice president pence stood strong
and certified the election vice
president pence showed us what it means
to be an american
what it means to show courage he put his
country
his oath his values and his morals above
the will
of one man the president had tried
everything in his power
to seize the um everything in his
attempt to seize power from the rightful
victor of the election
president trump's extraordinary actions
grew increasingly more desperate
you saw him go from pursuing claims in
the courts to threatening state and
local election officials
to then attacking members of congress in
the senate to compromising our justice
department
and then to attacking the republican
vice president
these great public servants were being
pressured by our commander-in-chief to
overturn the results
some of them and their families got
death threats
thankfully at every turn our democratic
processes prevailed
and the rule of law prevailed
it was only because all these people
stayed strong
and we refused president trump that our
republic
held fast and the will of the electorate
was seen through
and at this point president donald j
trump ran out of nonviolent options
to maintain power i began
to raise i began today by raising the
question
of how we got here what you saw was a
man
so desperate to cling to power that he
tried everything he could
to keep it and when he ran out of
non-violent measures
he turned to the violent mob that
attacked
your senate chamber on january 6.
as you cast your vote after this trial
i hope each of you will think of the
bravery of all these people
who said no to president trump because
they knew
that this was not right that this was
not
[Music]
america
next representative stacy plaskett the
virgin islands
will show in quite chilling detail i
should say how president trump
was well aware of the threat of violence
on january 6
and how he welcomed and amplified his
supporters plans
for insurrection against the union
i should say as lead manager this is a
moment of special pride for me because
representative plaskett
is not only the first delegate ever to
be
on a team of impeachment managers in
american history but she was also
my law student at american university's
washington
college of law and i hope i'm not
violating any federal educational
records laws when i say she was an a
student then and she's an a plus
student now stacy post
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much
height mr president
distinguished senators i'm stacy
plaskett
and i represent the people of the virgin
islands of the united states
over this past weekend my 11-year-old
daughter i overheard her telling one of
my sons
mommy doesn't seem really nervous about
the impeachment trial
to which that son sounding like an older
brother
said talia you'll learn that most of the
time
mommy really seems to have it under
control
now we know as parents that's not always
the case
but i've learned throughout my life that
preparation
and truth can carry you far
can allow you to speak truth to power
i've learned that as a young black girl
growing up in the projects
in brooklyn housing community
on st croy sent to the most unlikeliest
of settings
and now as an adult woman representing
an
island territory speaking to the u.s
senate
and because of truth i am confident
today
speaking before you because truth
and facts are overwhelming
that our president the president
of the united states incited a mob
to storm the capital to attempt to stop
the certification of a presidential
election
my fellow managers have shown it will
continue to show
clear evidence that president trump
incited a violent mob to storm
our capital when he ran out of
nonviolent means to stop the election
[Music]
once assembled that mob at the
president's direction
erupted into the bloodiest attack
on this capital since 1814.
some of you have said there's no way the
president could have known
how violent the mob would be
that is false because the violence
it was foreseeable i want to show you
why this violence was foreseeable
and why donald trump was different than
any other politician
just telling their fighters their
supporters
to fight for something the violence that
occurred
on january 6 like the attack
itself did not just appear
you'll see that donald trump knew the
people he was inciting
he saw the violence that they were
capable of
and he had a pattern and practice of
praising
and encouraging that violence never
condemning it and you'll see that this
violent attack
was not planned in secret the insurgents
believed that they were doing the duty
of their president they were following
his orders
and so they publicized it openly
loudly proudly
exact blueprints of how the attack would
be made
law enforcement saw these postings and
reported that these insurgents
would violently attack the capital
itself this was not just a com
a comment by an official to fight for a
cause
this was months of cultivating a base of
people
who were violent praising that violence
and then leading that violence that rage
straight at our door
the point is this by the time he called
the cavalry of his thousands of
supporters
on january 6 and an event
he had invited them to he had
every reason to know that they were
armed
that they were violent and that they
would actually
fight he knew who he was calling
and the violence they were capable of
and he still gave that marching orders
to go to the capitol and quote
fight like hell and stop
the steel make no mistake
the violence was not just foreseeable to
president trump
the violence was what he deliberately
encouraged as early as september
trump said the precedent that when asked
to denounce violence
he would do the opposite and encourage
it
now if the president had only said
something once about fighting to stop
the steel
and violence erupted there would be no
way to know
he intended to incite it or saw it
coming
but just as the president spent months
spreading his big lie of the election
he also spent months cultivating
groups of people who following his
command
repeatedly engaged in real
dangerous violence and when they did
when the violence erupted as a response
to his
calls to fight against the sole election
he did not walk it back he did not
tell them no he did the opposite
the opposite he praised
and encouraged the violence so that it
would continue
he fanned the flame of violence
and it worked you'll see this
over time these very groups and
individuals whose violence the president
praised helped lead the attack
on january 6th and that's how we know
clearly that president trump
deliberately incited this
and how we know he saw it coming
there are many examples where the
president engaged in this pattern
and i'm just going to walk you through a
few of them
let's start with the president's trump's
incitement of
the proud boys many of you have heard of
this group
which since 2018
has been classified by the fbi as an
extremist
organization since that classification
the group has repeatedly engaged in
serious
acts of violence including at pro-trump
rallies
and one such act on september 7th the
proud boys attacked a man
with a baseball bat and then punched him
while he was down on the ground
on september 29th during a presidential
debate
president trump was asked specifically
if he was willing to condemn white
supremacy
and militia groups if he was willing to
tell them
to stand down and stop the violence
let's watch but are you willing tonight
to condemn white supremacists and
militia groups
and to say that they need to stand down
and not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland are you
prepared
let's hear now the president's response
do it sir say it do it say it you want
to call him
what do you want to call him give me a
name give me a white surprise
stand back and stand by
when asked to condemn the proud boys
and white supremacists
what did our president say
he said stand back
and stand by his message
was heard loud and clear the group
adopted that phrase stand
back and stand by as their official
slogan they created merchandise with
their new slogan
which they wore proudly across their
backs
at trump's rallies and they followed the
president's orders
you'll see more about this later in the
trial but you'll see in these photos
to the left dominic pizzola and to the
right
william pepe two of the leaders of the
group
heading to the capitol on january six
they were later charged with working
together to obstruct law enforcement
as we go through this evidence i want
you to keep in mind these words by
president trump
when asked to condemn violence stand
back and stand by
and see example after example
of the kinds of people like the proud
boys
who he had standing by on january 6.
by october as my colleagues mr castro
and mr swalwell showed you
donald trump was escalating his big lie
that the only way he could lose the
election
was if it was rigged so as election day
neared
his supporters were frustrated and they
were angry
they were prepared to ensure his victory
by any means necessary one of these
violent acts was on october 30th
sometime after 12 30 pm a
caravan of more than 50 trucks covered
in pro-trump campaign gear
confronted and surrounded cars carrying
biden harris campaign workers
and a bob harris campaign bus as they
were traveling down
interstate 35 from san antonio
to austin
[Music]
according to witnesses this caravan
repeatedly tried to force the bus you
saw
and you see in that video to slow down
in the middle of their highway
and then to run it off the road what
that video you just saw
does not show is that the bus that they
tried to run off the road
was filled with young campaign staff
volunteers
supporters surrogates people
as the trump supporters closed in on the
bus
a large back black pickup truck adorned
with trump
flags suddenly and intentionally swerved
and
crashed into a car driven by a
biden-harris volunteer
news of the event went viral on social
media
the president of the united states in a
campaign
saw his own supporters trying to run
a bus carrying his opponent's campaign
workers
off the highway to physically
intimidate people in this country
campaigning
here was his response the next day
[Music]
three two one
[Music]
[Music]
the president of the united states
tweeted a
video of his supporters trying to
drive a bus off the road
you'll recall in that first video that i
showed you there was no sound
well the one that he tweeted how to
fight theme song plays to it
that the president the president put
that music
to that video and he added at the top
i love texas by the next evening
that tweet that he did had been viewed
12.6 million times
and it wasn't just a tweet on november
1st
at a michigan rally with the sieve
supporters
the president talked about that incident
again
here it is something do you see the way
our people they you know they were
protecting his bus yesterday
because they're nice so they had
hundreds of cars
trump trump trump and the american flag
that's a
you see trump and americans like
the president made a public joke of
violence against campaigners
in an american election
he made light of it this was not a joke
in fact it was so violent it put so many
people in harm's way
that the fbi investigated the incident
and the criminal responsibility of those
who attacked these campaign workers
now our president donald trump could
have said okay
i didn't realize how bad that was this
was very violent
please stop but he didn't
he saw the investigation and made a
statement
in defense of his supporters attack on
the bus writing quote
in my opinion these patriots
did nothing wrong engaging in violence
for him
made them patriots to donald trump
for anyone who says donald trump didn't
know the violence he was inciting
i ask you to consider his supporters
tried to drive a bus
off the highway in the middle of the day
to intimidate his opponent's campaign
workers and his response
was to tweet the video of the incident
that had
fight music joke about it and call
those individuals in that incident
patriots
and once again donald trump's pay praise
worked to incite them further emboldened
by that praise
they remained ready to fight
ready to stand back and stand
by this link is not hypothetical
just like we saw with a proud boy
showing up in full force
on january 6 donald trump's
encouragement of this attack
made sure his supporters were ready for
the next one
the caravan bus attack had been
organized by a trump supporter
named keith lee leading up to the attack
on our capital of january 6
mr lee teamed up with other supporters
to fundraise to help to bring people to
washington dc for that day
the morning of the attack he filmed
footage of the capital
pointed out the flimsiness of fencing
and then addressed his supporters before
the attack
saying quote as soon as you all get done
hearing
president you all get to the capitol
we need to surround this place
during the attack he used the bull horn
to call out for the mob to rush in
he later went to the rotunda himself
and then back outside to urge the crowd
to come inside these are the people
that president trump cultivated
who were standing by
i'd like to look at another example
[Music]
after the election on december 12th
trump supporters gathered in mass
to pro the stolen election in d.c
[Music]
it was built by his loyalists as the
second
million mega march
the or the rally was organized by women
for america first
the same group that you'll see later
secured the permit
for the january 6 rally and who else was
there
the proud boys standing by
donald trump did not attend that rally
but he made sure to make clear his
supporters throughout the day
how he felt about the event at 8
47 a.m he sent out a tweet
[Music]
we have just begun to fight
and then the rally began and donald
trump's allies
who spoke at the rally carried on his
message of the stolen election
and the importance of fighting to stop
the steel here's nicolas fuentes
a commentator who would organize a stop
the steel rally
in michigan with trump's supporters
and the first million bargain marks we
promised
that if the gop would not do everything
in their power to keep trump in office
that we would destroy the gop
and as we gather here in washington dc
for a second millionth of march
we're done making promises it has to
happen now
we are going to destroy the gop
[Music]
those words that was trump's message
destroy anyone who won't listen
who won't help them take the election
for trump and as you will see
this was just the preview for fuentes
who like the proud boys
and the trump caravan organizers would
later
heed the president's call and come to
washington
and be there on january 6.
later in the rally a former trump
campaign spokeswoman
katrina pearson also spoke during her
speech
she stated quote this isn't over
this is just beginning referring to the
fight to stop this deal
and then she added we knew both
republican and democrats were against
we people we the people we are
the cavalry no one's coming for us
it's clear that trump and some of his
supporters
saw this as war a fight against anyone
who was unwilling to do whatever it took
to keep donald trump in power we
are the cavalry and president trump
continued to reinforce his support of
these messages throughout the day
at 1 48 pm after both speeches
he retweeted his deputy chief of staff's
tweet
showing his crowd that he had flown over
on marine one and he tweeted quote
thank you patriots these people were as
you can see
gathered in mass and being told by the
president's allies
that their election had been stolen and
they were told
they were the cavalry no one else
could do it and after hearing these
speeches
and seeing the president's support this
is what
donald trump's cavalry was capable of
what's up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what you just saw was the violence that
ensued
after that rally the proud boys
after that rally engaged in serious acts
of violence
in downtown d.c some trump supporters
and self-identified proud boys
vandalize churches after that rally
if we look at these events it's clear
how we got here because what did the
president do after that
he turned right around and a little over
a week later
he began coordinating the january 6
save america rally with the same people
who had planned the second million mag
of march
you'll recall that the women for america
first had organized
that second million mega march they had
originally planned
rallies for january 20 january 22nd
and january 23rd after
the inauguration but donald trump had
other plans
on december 19th president trump
tweeted his save the date for january
six
he told his supporters to come to dc
for a big protest the day
billing it as wild
just days later women for america first
amended their permit to hold their rally
on january 6
pursuant to the president save the date
instead of
after the inauguration this
was deliberate reports confirm
that the president himself president
trump
became directly involved with the
planning of the event
including the speaking lineup even the
music to be played
just as he chose the music for his
retreat
of the caravan driving the biden harris
bus off the road
with that fight song and he brought the
same people who spoke
at the second million magum rally to
help as well
trump's campaign advisor katrina pearson
who you recall said on december 12th
that this is the
only the beginning we are the cavalry
also became directly involved in
planning the event they even sent out
invitations together this is amy cremer
one of the founders of women for america
first
tweeting the invitation tagging donald
trump and other organizers
inviting the same supporters who would
just engage
in serious violence at the second
million maga rally
to show up to the largest rally
to stop the steal and president trump
seemed to have
other plans for what was going to happen
at that rally too
women for america first had initially
planned for the rally goers
to remain at the ellipse until
the counting of the state electoral
slates
froze was completed just like they had
remained at freedom plaza
after the second million mega march
in fact the permit stated in no
uncertain terms that the march
from the ellipse was not permitted
it was not until after president trump
and his team
became involved in the planning that the
march from the ellipse
to the capital came about
in direct contravention of the original
permit
this was not a coincidence
none of this was donald trump over many
months
cultivated violence praised it
and then when he saw the violence his
supporters were capable of
he channeled it to his big
wild historic event
he organized january 6 with the same
people
that had just organized a rally
resulting in substantial violence
and made absolutely sure this time
these violent rally goers wouldn't just
remain
in place he made sure
that those violent people would
literally
march right here to our steps
from the ellipse to the capital
to stop the steel his
cavalry this was deliberate
and because the president of the united
states incited this
because he was orchestrating this
because
he was inviting them the insurgents were
not
shy about their planning they believed
they were following the orders of the
commander-in-chief
they were as the tweet we just saw quite
literally
his cavalry so they posted
exact blueprints of the attack
openly loudly proudly
and they did this all over public forums
these were not just hidden posts and
dark websites
that trump would not have seen quite the
opposite
we know the president trump's team
monitored these websites
we know this because his advisors
confirm it an ex-white house and
campaign insider
jill reed who has known both scovino and
the president for years
said there was no way that scovino and
the trump social media operation
would not have been aware of the plan
circulating online
to storm the capital because
and i quote the trump operation closely
monitored the web's
darkest corners ranging from mainstream
sites
such as twitter facebook and reddit to
fringe
message boards like 4chan and x-chan
now called x-con to the donald.win
an offshoot of a banned reddit community
dedicated to rabidly supporting all
things trump
they actively monitored the exact sites
like the donald.win on which these
insurrectionists
wrote their posts and so what would
trump and his team have seen
when they were monitoring these white
sites
what would his supporters have said they
would have seen
a clear road map of exactly
what happened this is an example of a
post that was captured from one of the
sites
dedicated to donald trump that we just
talked about
shortly before the site was taken down
and the meme reads quote the capital
is our goal everything else
is a distraction every corrupt
member of congress locked in one room
and surrounded by real americans
is an opportunity that will never
present
itself again let that sink
in think about that
the exact thing that happened on january
6
that was their goal and they said it
out loud on sites that the trump
administration
was actively monitoring a third
party site captured a post on the
donald.win
where one user posted quote
this cannot simply be a protest it has
to be the establishment
of the maga militia with the command
offices
set up with all further militia tactical
missions
spreading from there another user said
in response quote
we will have to achieve an actual
tactical victory like storming and
occupying the capital to have
the intended effect that's what they
understood
donald trump to want there it is
in black and white and they explained
why they felt justified in this
another poster on the forum the donald
wynn wrote on january 4th quote
if congress illegally certifies biden
trump would have absolutely no choice
but to demand
us to storm congress and kill
slash beat them up
donald trump will have no choice
that was what he made them believe to
the point
his supporters felt justified even in
carrying weapons
and storming our capital this was in
post after post here's another
when discussing how to carry guns into
dc
one noted quote yes it's illegal
but this is war and we are clearly in a
post-legal
phase of our society what
they treated it as a war and they meant
it
the morning of the attack under the
thread today i told my kids goodbye
one poster wrote today i had the very
difficult conversation with my children
the daddy might not come home from d.c
within a matter of hours that post
amassed 4 000 likes
president trump had truly made them
believe that their election had been
stolen
and that it was their patriotic duty to
fight to steal it back
patriotic a term he gave those
who use violence for him and they were
willing to say goodbye to their children
for this fight and their supporters
didn't just rely
on entering the capital with guns
haphazardly
they had maps of this building
they talked through which tunnels to use
and how to get to the senate chamber
some posted specific floor plans layouts
of the capitol
alongside hopes of overwhelming law
enforcement to quote
find the tunnels arrest the worst
posters also fixated on what they saw as
their ability to easily overwhelm the
capitol police
as quote there are only around two
thousand of them
and again they urge quote the capital is
our goal everything else is a
distraction
there were hundreds of these posts
hundreds monitored by the trump
administration
and these posts they were chillingly
accurate right down to communication
devices
a new affidavit filed by the fbi
described
preparations by the right-wing group the
proud boys
to storm the capital including using
earpieces
and walkie-talkies to direct movements
throughout the building
this happened that's the level of
planning
in advance that occurred they had ear
pieces on the slide you'll see proud boy
member dominic pizzola has an earpiece
in his right ear
consistent with the affidavit and in
addition to these detailed posts
they made clear why they thought they
should do this
why they thought they could do this it
wasn't just that they were doing it
following the president's orders they
thought he would help them
a third party site captured a post on
the donald.win again
the site monitored by trump's team and
he wrote
and wrote quote he meaning donald trump
in this instance
can order the naf guard to stand down if
needed
unfortunately he has no control over the
capitol police
but there are only around two thousand
of them and are
a lot are useless fat asses or girls
it's all right there the overall goal
maps of the capital the weapons
communication devices they even said
publicly openly proudly
that president trump will help them to
commandeer the national guard
so all they have to do is overwhelm the
2000 capitol police officers
this was reported in the nbc news and
the washington post
with headlines like violent threats
ripple through far-right internet forums
ahead of protests pro-trump forums erupt
with violent threats ahead of
wednesday's rally against the 2020
election
fox news also reported i'm back
everybody this is really interesting
stuff
um she she congresswoman is doing an
excellent job here
even quoting a proud boy member who said
they would quote
incognito and spread across downtown dc
in smaller numbers
city officials seeing these same
warnings also publicly warned
about the violence and unlawful weapons
at the event dc mayor muriel bowser
cautioned residents of the district of
columbia to avoid the downtown area
while the rally attendees were in town
federal law enforcement warned of these
threats also
on january 3rd a capitol police
intelligence report
warned of a violent scenario in which
congress itself could be the target
of the angry supporters of president
trump on january 6.
according to that report obtained by the
washington post
supporters of the current president see
january 6
2021 as the last
opportunity to overturn the results of
the presidential election
this sense of desperation and
disappointment
may lead to more incentive to become
violent
unlike previous post-election protests
the targets of the pro-trump supporters
are not necessarily the counter
protesters as they were previously
i i'm seeing tyt raided us which i
really appreciate thanks to tyt
also thanks to inconsolable who's been a
twitch sub
at tier 3 for 17 months which is crazy
i know people are joking about in-cell
stuff
i actually think that there is a serious
question as to whether
in-cell situations do relate to what
happened on january 6th i don't think
that that's actually a crazy thing
an online post where the user declared
the trump supporters should go to
washington
and get violent the supporters said
quote
stop calling this a march or a rally or
a protest
go there ready for war we get
our president or we die
these threat warnings were not just
hypothetical actual arrests occurred in
the days leading to the attack
on january 4th two days before the rally
one extremely well publicized arrest was
of a proud boy leader
who destroyed a church's black lives
matter banner
a month earlier during the december 12th
second million mega march report
emphasized that when he was arrested
he was carrying high capacity firearm
magazines
which he claimed were meant to be
supplied to another
rally attendee for january
6th by the night of january 6 attack
d.c police had already made six arrests
in connection with the planned protests
on charges of carrying weapons
ammunitions
assault assaulting police
[Music]
this is all in public view
all of it the truth is usually
seen and rarely heard truth is truth
whether denied or not and the truth
is president trump had spent months
calling his supporters to a march on a
specific day
at a specific time in specific
places to stop the certification
and leading up to the event there were
hundreds
hundreds of posts online showing that
his supporters took this as a call
to arms to attack the capital
there were detailed posts of plans to
attack online
law enforcement warned that these posts
were real threats
and even made arrests days leading up to
the attack
and yet in the face of all this
these credible warnings of serious
dangerous threats to our capital
when those thousands of people were
standing in front of president trump
ready to take orders
and attack this is what he said
we're going to the capitol
and we fight we fight like
hell and if you don't fight like hell
you're not going to have a country
anymore
and that's why this is different and
that's why he must be convicted
and disqualified
[Music]
see what's next representative dean
will now return to the events of january
6th itself
she will demonstrate president trump's
repeated incitement of the crowd
that morning as he directed them to the
capitol in his last ditch effort
to retain his hold on power
[Music]
really crafting a coherent narrative not
talking about
vinyl records or the political
preferences of their parents i mean
they're really staying on
the subject matter which is a very low
bar i understand but
if you watched yesterday you'd
understand why it's so relevant
[Music]
for me and for many americans january 6
is forever etched in our memories
i went to work with a sense of
excitement the start of my second term
in congress and the first time i would
participate in the certification of a
presidential election
and then we all know what happened i
know many of us have similar experiences
from that day but i'll briefly share
mine
i stood with colleagues in the gallery
above the house floor
to observe the arizona challenge moments
later police radios reported
a breach of the capitol grounds
someone shouted up to us duck
then lie down then ready your gas masks
shortly after there was a terrifying
banging on the chamber doors
i will never forget that sound shouts
and
panicked calls to my husband and to my
sons
instructions to flee and then the
constant whirring
of the gas masks filtering the air
the chamber of the united states house
of representatives turned to chaos
for donald trump it was a very different
day
earlier i showed you donald trump's
desperate attempts to maintain power
ignoring adverse court rulings attacking
elected officials
pressuring his justice department even
attacking his own vice president
you saw a man who refused to lose who
was desperate to retain
power by any means necessary you saw a
man
willing to attack anyone and everyone
who got in his way
and you saw a man who thought he could
play by different rules
he told his supporters as my colleague
miss plaskett just showed you
exactly what he thought those different
rules were
combat fight violence
[Music]
this was not just one speech this was
weeks and weeks of deliberate effort
by donald trump to overturn the election
results
so that he didn't have to give up the
presidency
the speech on january 6 builds on refers
to
and amplifies that same pattern the
pattern trump had used and broadcasted
for months
he refused to lose his attacks on others
and his different rules the only thing
different about his speech on january 6
from all these other times that we went
through
was that he was no longer telling his
base just that they had to fight to stop
the steel
he was finally telling them now is the
time to do it
here's the place and here's how for
weeks he urged his supporters to show up
at a specific time and place and when
they got there
he told them exactly what he wanted
let's start with his desperation you saw
how much planning went into january the
6th
and when the day arrived donald trump's
desperation
was in full force between the time he
woke up on
january the 5th and the start of the
save america
uh march that next day
he had tweeted 34 times when donald
trump wants to get his message across he
is not shy
as you all know these tweets were
relentless
and these tweets all centered on his
singular focus
his drum beat to motivate anger and
incite
his supporters his big lie
the president yeah so first of all 34 is
actually not that much for trump trump
trump's done hundreds of tweets in a day
before also just for comedic value
i would actually prefer to see the
tweets printed out on those oversized uh
posters
just because having them brought out by
an assistant in
like super oversized is visually
compelling but this is obviously
the content is what matters these tweets
but let me just highlight a few
at one in the morning he tweeted if vice
president mike pence comes through for
us we will win the presidency
mike can send it back this will look
familiar to you because mr liu just
showed you how trump had privately
he was pressuring and publicly attacking
his vice president
to stop the certification and when vice
president
pence refused when he explained that the
constitution
simply does not allow him to stop
certification
donald trump provoked his base to attack
him
the late in the evening tweet was no
different
it just got more forceful let's be clear
what donald trump was saying
that vice president pence could send
back
the certification was not true
for one thing all 50 state states had
ratified this election
and for another vice president pence
explained to him that he does not have
the power to unilaterally
overturn states votes and just send the
certification back
imagine having to expect donald trump
knew this but this was his
last chance to get his vice president to
stop the certification
and so he was willing to say or do just
about anything
these tweets attacking the election is
fraudulent attacking his vice president
and urging his supporters to fight
continued throughout the morning
here's another example at 8 17
a.m he tweeted all my cat mike pence
has to do is send it back to them and
back to the states and we win
[Music]
and we win not quite that's what he said
even though by then he had clearly
lost as trump continued tweeting the
save
america march at the white house was now
in full swing
the speakers who warmed up the crowd for
trump were members of his inner circle
family members his personal attorney
people president trump had deputized to
speak on his behalf
some of the speakers also spoke at the
second million maga march
which resulted in serious violence just
the name of that is funny the warm-up
acts on
january 6 focused on promoting donald
trump's big lie
they stoked the same fears a stolen
election
of fraud of ripping victory away from
them and the speakers told them what to
do about it
as the crowd erupted in fight for trump
chance throughout that morning donald
trump jr
urged that's the message these guys
better
fight for trump the speakers lasted
three
hours repeating president trump's
message and finally at about noon
donald trump took the stage with the
seal of the presidency
on his podium and the white house as his
backdrop
president trump spoke for more than 70
minutes his narrative was familiar
it was the same message we he had spent
months spreading to his supporters
the big lie the election was stolen
that they should never concede
and that his supporters should be
patriots and fight much harder to stop
the steel
to take back our country
the same phrases he'd spread for weeks
but now the message was immediate
now it was just no longer just fight it
was fight right now
all of us here today do not want to see
our election victory stolen
by emboldened radical left democrats
which is what they're doing
stolen by the fake news media that's
what they've done
and what they're doing we will never
give up we will never concede it doesn't
happen
reducing the temperature our country has
had enough
we will not take it anymore and that's
what this is all about
and to use a favorite term that all of
you people really came up with
we will stop the steal
hmm that set the tone our country has
had enough and we will not take it
anymore
he told them and us right at the
beginning that the only way to take back
the country
was to fight right let's look at what he
said next
and rudy you did a great job
[Applause]
you know what he's got guts unlike a lot
of people in the republican party
he's got guts he fights
miss plaskett showed you example after
example of donald trump
when confronted with violence praising
it
we saw him instruct the proud boys a
violent extremist group
to stand back and stand by stand back
and stop the pope was there on january
the 6th
we saw him praise a caravan of his
supporters
after they tried to drive a bus
belonging to the biden campaign
off the road he loved it the organizer
of that attack was there on january the
6th called it the hot new thing and we
saw him team up with the organizers of
the violent
second mega million march to plan his
rally on january the 6th
and what does he do at that rally he
tells giuliani he's doing a great job
addressing the
crowd saying he has guts
to call for fighting and to be clear
this is what he was praising she should
play the clip of rudy
oh here it is
let's have trial by combat there it is
[Applause]
trial by combat donald trump praised
rudy
said he did a good job had guts for
telling the crowd
rudy reportedly dropped three silent
bombs during that statement too
next more attacks
all vice president pence has to do
is send it back to the states to
recertify
and we become president and you are the
happiest people
this attack like the tweets he sent that
morning had a purpose
convincing his supporters that the
future of our country of our democracy
hinged on whether vice president pence
would overturn
the election something he knew pence
could not
and would not do he called out vice
president pence
nine times that day and each time
he got more forceful here's what he said
at 12 15
and we're gonna have to fight much
harder and mike pence is gonna have to
come through for us
and if he doesn't that will be a sad day
for our country
right because you're sworn
to uphold our constitution
now it is up to congress to confront
this egregious assault
on our democracy really
we're going to walk down and i'll be
there with you we're going to walk down
we're going to walk down anyone you want
but i think right here we're going to
walk down
to the capitol pennsylvania
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
and we're probably not going to be
cheering so much for
some of them because you'll never
take back our country with weakness
right you have to show strength and you
have to be strong
[Applause]
god bless the united sheish carter and
mike pence will have to come through for
us
that's what he said and he told the
crowd what he meant
and exactly what to do literally
commanding them to confront
us at the capitol he even told them he'd
walk there with them
which of course was not true and then he
told them exactly what to do when they
got to the capitol
you'll never take your country back with
weakness you have to show strength
and don't forget who is standing there
the same people ms plaskett described to
you
many people violent violent people law
enforcement had warned
would be armed and would be targeting us
one of president trump's key defenses
focus
on what he said for a few seconds
15 minutes into the speech
i know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the capitol building
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard
in a speech spanning almost eleven
thousand words
yes we did check that was the one time
the only time president trump used the
word peaceful
or any suggestion of non-violence
the implication of the president's
tweets the rally and the speeches were
clear
president trump used the word fight or
fighting 20 times
including telling the crowd they needed
to fight like hell
to save our democracy we know how the
crowd responded to donald trump's words
and he knew how they responded to his
speech
here is the evidence of how the crowd
[Music]
reacted
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
yes
imagine going to a trump event and being
this far away by the way how depressing
is that like how bad is
your life gone that you're willing to
stand this far away and be happy about
[Applause]
it
[Music]
invade the capital fight
fight fight fight
take the capital right now these
were the words of the crowd trump was
telling them to fight and he would keep
telling them to fight throughout the
rest of his speech
these are not only words of aggression
they are words of insurrection
and if you have any doubt listen to what
he says next
today we see a very important event
though because right over there
right there we see the event going to
take place
and i'm going to be watching because
history is going to be made
we're going to see whether or not we
have great and courageous leaders or
whether
or not we have leaders that should be
ashamed of themselves
throughout history throughout eternity
they'll be ashamed
and you know what if they do the wrong
thing
we should never ever forget that they
did
never forget wow we should never ever
forget
the commander-in-chief points to
congress
and tells those assembled i'm going to
be watching
history is going to be made this was
clearly not just some rally or
march or protest this was about donald
trump
trying to steal the election for himself
claiming that the election was
fraudulent
illegitimate so that his supporters
would fight to take it back
in fact after stoking the crowd's anger
for nearly 40 minutes after repeating
false election conspiracy after false
election conspiracy he said
this in no uncertain terms you will have
an illegitimate president that's what
you'll have
any outcome besides him keeping the
presidency would be illegitimate
this was building on the big lie of a
rigged and stolen election
and here's what he said a little later
in the speech
when you catch somebody in a fraud
you're allowed to go by
very different rules really so i hope
mike has the courage to do what he has
to do wow
when you catch somebody in a fraud
you're allowed to go by
very different rules we told you that
context matters here's the context
this was not just one reference or a
message to supporters by a politician
to fight for a cause he'd assembled
thousands of violent
people people he knew were capable
of violence people he had
i know that it's different but when i
hear a fraud i think of
i will have a marijuana please
lit the fuse and sent an angry mob
to to fight the perceived enemy his own
vice president
and the members of congress as we
certified an election
but i said something's wrong here
something's really wrong
can't have happened and we fight we
fight like hell
and if you don't fight like hell you're
not going to have a country anymore our
exciting adventures and boldest
endeavors
have not yet begun my fellow americans
for our movement
for our children and for our beloved
country
and i say this despite all that's
happened
the best is yet to come
so we're going to
we're going to walk down pennsylvania
avenue i love pennsylvania
and we're going to the capitol and we're
going to try and give
the democrats are hopeless they're never
voting for anything
right not even one vote but we're going
to try
and give our republicans the weak ones
because the strong ones don't need any
of our help
we're going to try and give them the
kind of pride
and boldness that they need to take back
our country
so let's walk down pennsylvania avenue
i want to thank you all god bless you
and god
bless america thank you all for being
here this is incredible thank you very
[Applause]
much
it would be amazing if they were able to
work in the clip of trump saying you're
going to have to flush toilets 10 to 15
times under joe biden i know it's not
germaine to the impeachment but it i
mean the presentations have been so good
i would love it if they included that
if you don't fight like hell you're not
going to have a country anymore
and there was only one fight left and it
was a mile up the road
donald trump the president of the united
states ordered the crowd to march on
congress
and so the crowd marched this is
incredible
you heard him say that's how president
trump ended his speech
i'd like to close with a very brief
timeline of what was happening in
parallel alongside
the president as he she's not going to
list her favorite beatles albums
a little afternoon president trump began
his speech
with a fiery refusal to concede
he commanded the crowd to fight and
march down pennsylvania avenue
and around 12 20 some rally-goers some
attendees
began marching by 12 30 as president
trump continued to incite his supporters
large segments of the rally crowd had
amassed at the capitol
at 12 53 as the president's speech was
playing on cell phone broadcasts
the outermost barricade of the northwest
side
of the capitol was breached
and capitol police were forced back to
the steps of the capitol
at 1 10 the president ended his speech
with a final call to fight
and a final order to march to the
capitol
at 1 45 the president's followers
surged past capitol police shouting this
is a revolution
just after 2 10 an hour after president
trump ended his speech the
insurrectionist mob
overwhelmed capital security and made it
inside the halls of congress
because the truth is this attack
never would have happened but for donald
trump
[Music]
and so they came draped in trump's flag
and used our flag the american flag
to batter and to bludgeon
and at 2 30 i heard that terrifying
banging on house chamber doors
for the first time in more than 200
years
the seat of our government was ransacked
on our watch
wow
we will hear from jamie raskin mr
president um i think this would be a
good time for a break
[Music]
all right we will have a 16-minute break
and a lot
a lot a lot to catch up on here um
uh i mean listen there's there's two
separate questions here
one is about this the quality of this
presentation and it's done
extraordinarily well the second one is
whether any republicans are actually
listening to this and saying i i maybe i
should
maybe i should convict no because it is
not going to be a secret ballot
there's not going to be uh there will
not be 17 republicans that are willing
to publicly
vote to convict that's just not going to
happen and
um as a result of that we may feel that
this is a huge waste of time
unfortunately now i
one thing that's being meant although
it's not it is the responsibility
for this to be done here one of the
things that's interesting is that
and a few people in the chat were
talking about this trump's defense
lawyers
if they can get off the topics of what
foods their parents liked and
you know whether they're friendly with
the pennsylvania senators or not
if they can actually get onto substance
they will argue that donald trump didn't
really direct
any violence um well listen
it's called incitement the point is
whether trump's
speech incited people
not whether he literally said go out and
break in
and steal stuff from nancy pelosi's
office and so so that's
going to be something you're going to be
hearing frequently at some point from
trump's defense attorneys whoever
survives the guy from yesterday trump
furious with him
um but we'll have time to talk about
that once
um trump's attorneys uh
take over and i think that's a important
legal distinction
and also an important um
colloquial distinction as well i want to
say a huge
thank you to people who have been
supporting the stream it's been a couple
hours
since i thanked anybody so let me do
that bolo 510
just signed up for 14 months in a row
with prime
1801 is an additional 23
which puts us at uh wait 23 puts us
at 89 and i do want to thank some people
who signed up on my website and
just indulged me for a moment because
there are quite a few thomas dundon
signed up at joinedpakman.com maddie
wall
signed up at joinedpakman.com
christopher camp
is a new member also want to say
thank you to hold on a second don't want
to miss anybody jonathan prince
and adam washington appreciate that
and that is um puts us at 94 which is
perfect
we're still figuring out exactly how to
code the coupon code
to i guess not confuse people we got rid
of the quotes
seems to be helping to some degree and
for people asking
if something is wrong with my throat if
i'm sick no every time i use this
microphone
i get 20 emails from people asking if
i'm sick it's just people aren't used to
the way this microphone sounds
different voice processor different
microphone different room tone
that's all that is uh that's all that's
that's going on okay so everybody
everybody relax let's get to a few super
chats
um okay uh did i see how inaccurate the
closed captions
are yeah they're not super accurate you
know people keep
i turn them on and some people say turn
them off i turn them off and people say
turn them on
we're leaving the closed captions on for
the time being all right
imagine calling yourself a patriot while
flying a loser flag in the capital in
the name of your holy warlord king well
sarah things are very backwards right
now
elektron wants to know if we ever found
out what caster was talking about
we didn't by the way i have some really
funny clips these
we these are on today's podcast i hope
you guys are signed up
to the free podcast but i have some
hilarious
clips check this out um
sean hannity even multiple times had to
say
castor was not particularly good check
this out
i think you're going to like these
a bit of a weak start hold on we want to
get all those
let's make sure we have audio here and
let's listen to it from the beginning
active i thought it was a little bit of
a weak start i'm not being critical just
a little lackluster meandering to me
what the the material about vinyl
records was not uh you didn't think that
that that was relevant to the entire
thing
and then when interviewing trump's other
lawyer david shone
he brought it up again this is so funny
your arguments i loved your passion i
thought it started a little meandering
it was sort of like a lot of free
associating in the beginning
are you saying it was a verbal rorschach
test sean
you're saying that talking about his the
favorite senator of his parents
was not relevant and i'm not i'm i'm not
attacking your partner i don't i don't
know him at all
isn't that just great even hannity
could not possibly sugarcoat it and if
people are wondering like i'm really not
exaggerating
um hold on aaron rupar had him i think i
have the
the direct links here's some examples of
bruce castor yesterday
i was growing up in uh suburban
philadelphia
right my parents were big fans of
senator everett dirksen from illinois
now understand
everett dirksen being supported or not
by this guy's parents the entire case is
writing on that
we don't yet know how at some point
they're going to reveal it for us
and uh senator dirksen recorded a series
of
lectures right and you know compared to
modern recording technology you may find
the audio quality not to be great
but certainly better than on a
phonograph um
and you know bitrate i don't know uh oh
sorry sorry sorry my parents had on a
record
and we still know what records are right
right on the thing you put the needle
down on and play it
right and uh
here's little bruce 8 9 now some of the
recordings were out of phase
and my mom more so than my dad was
bothered
by out of phase recordings but
ultimately as recording technology
improved we were able to solve that
problem
10 years old listening to this back in
the late 60s
and i would be listening to that voice
if you ever heard everett dirksen's
voice it's the most commanding gravelly
voice that just just oozes
belief and sincerity and you know my dad
he didn't find men with tenor voices
that manly and i said dad not
everybody's a baritone and it was a
point of disagreement at family dinners
but eventually we were able to
have an okay relationship must have been
a phenomenal united states senator
he does this went on and on and on
here's another one did bruce castor
take a wrong turn and end up at the
wrong trial it's crazy trump was
reportedly screaming as this was going
on
they love the states that they represent
there isn't a member in this room
who has not used the term
i represent the great state of
fill in the blank right why because
they're all great yeah
but you think yours is greater than
others because
uh we've lost the audio there why is it
that they think that they're greater i
don't even know
these are your people okay these are the
people that
sent you here to do their
work they trusted you
it was just endless
so senators are patriots senators are
family men and women
they're fierce advocates for the great
state in which they represent
and somewhere far down that list of
attributes
way below patriot and way below love of
family
and country and way below
like how much of it can i really play
you know i don't know about off the top
of my head but
each one of them once there was the
vacuum created
that the greatest deliberative bodies
the senate of greece and
sitting in athens the senate of rome
the moment that they devolved into such
partisanship
what's funny is he thought he was doing
dui defense but even as a dui defense
this is still terrible i was going to
say
it will instead of flood gates i was
going to say originally it will
release the whirlwind which is a
political
a biblical reference but i subsequently
learned since i got here that that
particular phrase has already been taken
so i figured i'd better change this is a
funny thing he spent a lot of it saying
listing things he was not going to say
like listing things he thought of saying
but has opted out of saying he listed a
lot of that stuff
and this is just really funny bruce
castor making rudy giuliani look like
cicero
very very strange just really bizarre
and
one other just really funny note
apparently
initially the plan was for david shone
to go first and bruce castor to go
second
and that because they were surprised
that democrats used footage of the riots
they switched
i don't even understand that explanation
but it's not like if you have them go
second it's any better i mean
every every detail is is crazy
it doesn't make any sense um okay
very good so we've gotten that we're in
a brief break scheduled to restart at
4pm eastern time
i want to say thanks to techolote and
fifi boy
for signing up uh via twitch prime in
fact four people did which puts us
at 98.
and also uh thank you to alexander casas
and dirk bastert von bruno
putting us at exactly 100
you know what i like to say let's go for
two why not
let's go for two okay other super chats
coming in
um david do you think there's a
correlation between intelligence and
gullibility the more intelligent you are
the less gullible
no i i don't know that it's that clear
um for example
think about uh gullibility to tech scams
there's lots of
really smart people really smart people
um you know doctors college professors
etc
who merely because of naivete around
technology
they're more liable to fall for some of
these phishing scams
it's i don't know that it's that clear
of a correlation intelligence and
gullibility i think it's more
complicated than that
uh robert says keep up the good work
appreciate that
what's the barrier for a secret vote
this is a good question they could
decide on this being a secret vote
when they eventually vote by a simple
majority but it would only take 20
republicans to
to cancel it so uh that's
reportedly why they're not going forward
with it david do you think it's
plausible that a lot if not most
republicans know how wrong this is but
they're not willing to convict trump
anyway
due to a loss of constituents perhaps
absolutely absolutely
i think ted cruz is nutty enough that he
really thinks
that acquittal is correct i think
there's lots of republican senators that
know that a conviction is appropriate
and um they're just not considering it
for uh for political reasons michael
says i have a feeling the republican
senators are going to say that they're
voting against conviction
because of how compelling the defense
was absolutely you are going to have
republicans who say i came into this
with an open mind
and i just listened to both sides and uh
the defense counsel made a great case
period
there's no uh there's no question that
that is going to happen for some of
these folks
some of these folks okay
other super chats judd westgate says i
sent your logic series to my trumpist
family members thanks for being a beacon
of sanity and logic
thank you i don't i'm not super
optimistic that's going to change their
mind david what's your favorite
springsteen record i'm just i'm not
knowledgeable enough about springsteen's
uh discography to be able to say
david use an underlined or quoted code
for colorblind folks yeah that's that's
an interesting idea
um what else do we have here all right i
think i'm caught up from the standpoint
of super chats you're not missing
anything guys this video over here is
earlier that's congressman
uh ted liu that is from earlier live is
on the left side of the screen and uh
the senate chamber
is in a brief brief recess
a brief resist scheduled to go just two
more minutes
probably will go you know a little a
little bit longer than that would be my
expectation do i have more unban
requests
no i don't think so we earlier we did a
segment where i went through unban
requests with you guys and we
adjudicated them
live on stream and there were i did do
some unbans and then there were also
some confirmed permabans i i don't think
i have any more
we we really only get a few every once
in a while
uh let me see here it's looking like
zero yeah i don't have any
unban requests
not currently okay up tomorrow on the
show i will be talking about
there is now an actual criminal
investigation going on
um in georgia because of donald trump's
supposedly perfect phone call asking for
11
780 votes i'm going to be talking about
that on the program tomorrow
what else do we have we'll review day
two of the impeachment of course
uh we have an interview tomorrow what
who is on tomorrow i don't even know
let's see
oh oh we're actually we're interviewing
michael kinch tomorrow who has a book
on the history of vaccines i think it'll
be very illuminating for some of the
anti-vaxx folks
we will talk about georgia prosecutors
open a criminal investigation of the
trump call
we will talk about what else do i have
yeah the tomorrow is already a big show
yeah i i don't i'm not going to preview
everything but tomorrow
tomorrow may actually be a good one
unlike so many of them uh tyler dennis
says what about the dude crying over the
poem
yes yesterday now which of the two
attorneys was it that cried over the
poem was
it was david shone right not bruce
castor
yeah it was shown right good lord i
wasted so much more money than i thought
look at other super chats trump is the
next ross perot okay i'm sorry let me
find
other super chats mabo6
what are your thoughts on conviction i
don't think it will happen
mcconnell avoiding perot repeat i didn't
understand that one
okay i wanted to save a little money the
path to the guilty verdict is behind the
scenes mcconnell's pushing republicans
to vote guilty because he doesn't want a
repeat of ross perot do you really think
trump wouldn't run again
i wouldn't put it past mcconnell to do
that i just don't think it'll work
i don't think mcconnell is going to
convince 17 republicans to vote to
convict
nurse betty says i think there's about
70 million racists in the united states
their hate is more powerful than truth
or logic
and that's why they worship trump i i
don't know
i don't know um
i mean to say you know i think a lot of
people have uh preconceived notions
based on race
and many other categories
uh i i can't say with certitude there
are 70 million
racists
messages coming in via twitch sub dollar
battery says thanks for all you do david
your show keeps me sane while at work
appreciate that
um siree
you're blue says glad you're streaming
david your commentary keeps me calmer
oh our friend lars baron roth from the
deeper shades of house twitch
channel says finally able to tune in for
a live session
uh turning into a streaming machine
myself yeah you guys can check out
twitch.tv deeper shades of house
and uh thank you to scarlet lighting and
artific
art aficionado interesting spelling
there
very very interesting uh we are not
missing anything
everybody relax this is earlier on the
right side of the screen
live senate recess scheduled to be back
two minutes ago and we'll be uh probably
coming back within the next
five to ten minutes or something like
that
everybody calm everybody calm no big
deal uh
big thank you to daniel chapman
who just signed up at joinpackman.com
and also thank you to
larry spencer who just signed up at
joinpackman.com thanks guys
appreciate that how long is this
expected to go
i don't know the answer to that my so my
thought is
um the house managers get eight hours
for their presentations
because we're already four hours in and
they're coming back
my guess is they're gonna try to go with
all eight hours today has any
does anybody know for sure one way or
the other i i've not heard them say but
they may go the full eight hours today
meaning this could go until you know
with breaks 9 pm
9 30 something like that i probably will
not be able to
stream all of that um at some point
i've got other stuff i need the computer
for and i'm not going to be able to keep
streaming
people think so oh one hour then they go
on a vacation yeah there you go
interesting so they're going oh wow
they're gonna go the full eight hours
okay
yeah so i'll probably do the next couple
hour section
and then we'll be back with you tomorrow
nurse betty says how many people voted
for trump in 2020 about 75 million
ivan says we can't see super chat is
that on purpose no i don't have my
normal setup today
i uh i have an extra monitor down here
i am uh in the i believe tomorrow i will
have
what i need in order to put super chats
up on the screen i just you know
in my normal setup i've got five
monitors and it's much easier to
um put those up on the screen just
unable with the current setup
but we're gonna get that set up very
soon caleb says my neighbor's flag
according to google is the stripes of
rebellion it's replaced his trump flag
have also seen his come and take it and
others yeah a lot of people write to me
about the flags
that their uh neighbors have and how a
lot of flags were quietly taken down
the day after uh or or days
after the election
okay what else do we have going on
there's there's people
in twitch chat who are furious with me
and i can't tell why
somebody's always mad what am i not
talking about that people need me to
talk about
an executive order guys i don't know you
know we're dealing we're dealing with uh
we're dealing with impeachment right now
people are people are always mad i don't
even get it just i'm always doing the
wrong thing no matter what's going on
isn't it obvious like the
insurrectionist caster and david shone
are antifa plants being perfect
purposely useless to scuttle trump
i i wouldn't be shocked if somebody said
that
i wouldn't be shocked if somebody said
that
somebody's furious about the coupon code
okay
can't can't do much about that um
oh do i have any voicemails that's a
that's a fair question let's see
i haven't looked we had a really wacky
voicemail yesterday let me see if i have
anything extra
probably extra wacky would be fair to
say
uh let's see here
i don't know oh no i do here's a troy
let's just listen i know troy york is
divisive among the community
let's just see what he said
yeah favorite pac-man this is troy lore
wow i'm just watching that greg hunter
as usual i have no clue who these people
are
greg hunter the bosch twins you know all
these different
people he has his own channel he's not
on youtube anymore because youtube
censors the
freedom and rights of individuals from
expressing themselves
debating the election fraud
what is he talking about does anybody
understand what he's saying
he had craig paul roberts on his program
now correct paul roberts
sounds like john wayne gacy i never know
who these people are that troy watches
i would love to see you debate craig
paul roberts
um former treasury secretary to ronald
reagan
and he is a viable great speaker paul
craig roberts is on many youtube
channels
and he pretty much explains how this
country
pretty much explains i like that the
left wing has no respect for tradition
for this country
craig paul roberts says that we're
moving into a dictatorship
you know that this is something that's
very common that these right-wingers
will do um they'll come up with
arguments like
you know this entire impeachment really
goes against tradition hold on a second
did trump do something worthy of
impeachment if yes then the house should
impeach
if the house impeaches there should be a
senate trial
the members of the senate should then
adjudicate guilty or not guilty
it's like they're violating tradition
sort of one of those meaningless
arguments
it's one of the meaningless fundamentals
of conservatism right to conserve
what was done before merely for the sake
of of
conserving it style soviet states of
america type
ideology and this has been brought upon
i believe
he doesn't say but i'll say craig paul
roberts won't say this but i'll say this
that
it's been broad brown by massive
immigration did he say it's been brought
brown is that a freudian slip about when
he says immigration does he mean brown
people
seems like a freudian racist slip how
socialists leading
sons of [ __ ] from throughout the
world
who have no uh
care for our constitution don't care
about this country
paul craig roberts is a great man he's a
patriot
and we need more people like paul craig
roberts to
resist this growing off up the period
direction that the democrat party seeks
to establish a one-party state
they want to impeach by the way this
goes the full two minutes and 59 seconds
which is the max
for a voicemail and then it just cuts
and is no longer
present for their kabuki theater
they go after anyone who is not of the
established political wing
whether it be from the light left or the
right if it's mitch mcconnell or mitt
romney
or chuck schumer or nancy pelosi but
those people are set they're not
attacked but anyone who goes against
those two political established career
politicians
all right i don't know what he's talking
about the senate's back though and i'll
be back with you guys shortly
resuming with the prosecution's case
just as a reminder
we're about uh four hours in today they
get eight hours
not sure what this delay is maybe just
people sitting down
we'll see who's going next
prosecution continues for people asking
the prosecution continues
i believe is this bruce castor right
here
[Music]
and this is david shone i believe that's
what we've got going on here
here's jamie raskin
of course senator patrick leahy
presiding over this
we have order in the senate please
thank you mrs good thank you mr
president members of the senate um
at this point uh representatives
plaskett and swalwell
will take you through the actual day of
the attack
uh they will recreate the attack as it
unfolded focusing on the threats to vice
president pelosi
vice president pence speaker pelosi the
joint session
and law enforcement um
i i do want to alert everyone that there
is
some very graphic uh violent footage uh
coming just so people
are aware and i'm going to call again on
miss plaskett who i should also tell you
uh went to work at the department of
justice and was the senior counsel for
deputy attorney general
larry thompson under attorney general
ashcroft so
she's a very well trained and
experienced prosecutor as you can tell
i'm just gonna hang a few more minutes
and see what she's bringing to the table
here
mr president senators
almost all of us were here on january 6
and we all have our individual
experiences
what we felt what we saw
what we heard we've seen clips and
reports in the media
but i have to tell you it was not until
preparing for this trial
that i understood the full
scope and learned the information that
you're going to see
that i understood the effort to attack
our seat of government
in order to carry out president trump's
mission
to prevent the certification of a
presidential election
it was an attack to our republic
to our democratic process
my colleagues manager swalwell and i
are going to walk you through the attack
onto the camera you know what guys
unfortunately i'm gonna have to make a
particular decision
we did get a uh strike warning
um when certain video from january 6th
accidentally got on air on january 6th
and the risk we just i just can't risk
losing streaming ability on twitch and
youtube so i think we're gonna i'm gonna
have to cut out it's just too much of a
risk and i don't know exactly when it's
coming
um and we we are like
we were very close to getting banned on
twitch altogether it's not for the music
it's for the violent because they may be
showing
video of the of the shooting and um
it's just too risky it's just too risky
so since this is going to be presented
today
i'm just going to cut here okay before
they go to that i apologize
you youtube is just as risky i i want to
stay brand safe and we don't want to
risk being unable to be here tomorrow
okay
i'm just getting messages from people um
at both twitch and youtube about that
and
i just can't take the risk okay so
there's plenty of other
streams going on we'll we'll cut our
stream here we're for about four hours
in
and i'll be back with everybody tomorrow
all right need to stay safe and uh you
know we
if we can't stream for the next six
months because five seconds of video get
out
it's just too risky all right we'll see
everybody tomorrow